une séance est ouverte
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle pour la bonne compréhension de
nos débats que les temps de parole sont
limités à deux minutes par intervenant
les questions et les réponses et que
pour la bonne compréhension des
téléspectateurs nous avons inséré un
chronomètre sur la retransmission télé
parce que certains s'étonnaient que les
prises de parole étaient coupées et donc
ces deux minutes pour tout le monde et
j'espère que vous respecterez comme
d'habitude cette règle la première
question va être posée par Monsieur
vulfran du groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente permettez-moi de
dire
solennellement
toute ma solidarité avec
la ESH du collège Le Cannet à Rouen
mutilé d'un doigt suite au tir d'une
grenade de désencerclement durant la
manifestation du 23 mars
à son image
à son image que toutes les victimes de
violence d'où elles viennent
reçoivent tout le soutien auquel elles
ont droit madame la Première ministre
cette interpellation n'est pas une
question d'actualité au gouvernement le
groupe GDR et les députés communistes
n'attendent pas de réponse d'un
gouvernement qui refuse de répondre aux
Français et méconnais l'actualité
sociale le groupe GDR n'atteint pas de
réponse d'un gouvernement qui compromet
la Concorde dans notre pays et n'a pas
l'intérêt général communique boussole le
groupe GDR n'attend donc pas de réponse
du gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron à
cette interpellation
son interpelle nation s'adresse à nos
concitoyens
désirez-vous un référendum sur les
retraites pour sortir le pays de
l'impasse de crise à haut risque dans
lequel un certain gouvernement incertain
la piégé si oui faites grandir cette
exigence
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
ça n'était donc pas votre question ce
n'est pas votre question mais ça sera ma
réponse et celle du gouvernement
simplement pour vous dire Monsieur le
Député que lorsque vous dites que ce que
vous assurez ou ce que vous prétendez
pardon que ce gouvernement ne souhaite
ni la Concorde ni la réussite c'est tout
l'inverse tout l'inverse parce qu'avec
cette réforme des retraites nous n'avons
qu'un objectif garantir la pérennité
d'un système par répartition vous y êtes
attaché garantir la pérennité d'une
solidarité intergénérationnelle et faire
en sorte que ce système de retraite qui
est déficitaire puisse perdurer vous
savez monsieur le député je pense que
vous partagerez au moins ce point avec
moi je n'ai aucune inquiétude pour
celles et ceux de nos concitoyens qui
sont les plus fortunés les plus riches
la capitalisation la capacité à préparer
leur avenir la capacité à investir ils
l'ont ils l'ont toujours eu et ils
seront toujours sur sortir ce qui
m'intéresse et ce qui m'inquiète le plus
sont ceux justement qui n'ont pas les
moyens de préparer l'avenir et c'est
pour eux que nous sauvons ce système de
retraite c'est parce que la réforme que
nous portons permet de conserver un
système de retraite qui leur permettra à
eux les plus d'avoir un revenu décent
une fois lors du repos arrivée
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
allez-y monstres
que les propos du groupe GDR
n’appelaient aucune réponse du
gouvernement
la seule réponse qui vaille pour nous
désormais c'est le vote des Français
seuls dénouement démocratique dont nous
ne doutons pas qu'il sanctionne
définitivement le retrait de cette
réforme
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marie Fiévet
pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
ce samedi 25 mars à Sainte-Soline nos
efforts nos forces de l'ordre ont été la
cible de plusieurs milliers d'individus
radicaux violents infiltré dans les
manifestation non autorisées contre les
réserves de substitution et armées de
cocktail Molotov de mortier de hache et
d'autres projectiles très dangereux
face à cette violence au résultat d'une
tristesse accablante nous avons assisté
à des scènes d'affrontements choquantes
au cours desquelles des véhicules de nos
forces de l'ordre ont été incendiés et
de nombreuses personnes blessées
je tiens d'ailleurs au nom du groupe
Renaissance a souhaité un bon
établissement à tous les blessés ainsi
qu'à apporter nos soutien à nos forces
de l'ordre pour leur engagement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai aussi une pensée pour ne pas
confier des Deux-Sèvres et pour le SAMU
qui a su répondre présent mais également
pour nous agriculteurs qui subissent
depuis plusieurs mois dégradation et
menaces face à ces images intolérables
et à l'inverse des élus de la nupesse
présent à manifestation ou qui se
réjouissent des ordres sociales au point
de lancer des fake news en allant
jusqu'à annoncer hier la mort de
manifestants j'en appelle à l'apaisement
et à la raison
non non déplaise à certains notre
démocratie prévoit le droit aux
opposants de manifester pacifiquement
mais en aucun cas l'usage de la violence
et les manifestations illégales ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quelle mesure vendez-vous
prendre face à des événements d'une
violence inacceptable personne ne dessus
de nos lois et de telles affrontements
ne peuvent et ne doivent se reproduire
quelle mesure prévoyez-vous vis-à-vis
des organisateurs tels que les
collectifs bassines non merci ou encore
l'association le soulèvement de la terre
qui était à l'initiative de cette
manifestation bien qu'elle soit
interdite je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente permettez-moi
madame la Présidente tout d'abord
d'avoir au nom de la prairie du
gouvernement une pensée pour le maréchal
des logiciels Arnaud blanc militaires du
GIGN mort en mission voilà quelques
jours malheureusement en Guyane
merci pour pour lui pour juger les pour
sa famille monsieur le député vous
m'interrogez dans votre département vous
le savez ce week-end c'est passé des
événements inqualifiables la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres depuis plusieurs jours
depuis le 17 mars avait interdite la
manifestation à Sainte-Soline et aux
abords de sainte Soline et par deux
conférences de presse et par celle de
Monsieur le Procureur de la République
chacun connaissait cette interdiction de
manifestation nous avons parce que nous
savions malheureusement depuis six mois
et le premier événement à sainte-soling
qui avait déjà fait naître 61 gendarmes
blessés dont plusieurs très gravement
des confrontations radicales avec comme
vous l'avez dit des violences
inacceptables contre les biens et
surtout contre les personnes évidemment
les 47 militaires de la gendarmerie mais
également plusieurs manifestants et je
veux aussi avoir une pensée pour ceux
qui luttent pour la vie en ce moment et
pour les blesser et je veux dire bien
évidemment notre compassion à chacune et
puisque aucune cause ne peut justifier
ces violences cependant je constate
comme vous l'extrême violence de
certains groupuscules ont les services
de renseignement démontrent qui sont à
la fois fichées par les services de
renseignement parfois depuis de très
nombreuses années et qui sont
responsables de grande violence et je
pense notamment évidemment au groupement
de faits des soulèvements de la terre
plusieurs envahissements d'entreprises
plusieurs exactions fortes contre les
forces de l'ordre plusieurs destructions
de biens plusieurs des centaines de
gendarmes ou de policiers blessés
plusieurs en effet appel à
l'insurrection j'ai donc décidé
d'engager la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre que je
proposerai après contradictoire à un
prochain conseil des ministres
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Laurent jacobelli
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
à Sainte-Soline ce week-end comme à
chaque fois des Black Blocs et des
groupes d'ultra gauche sont venus mener
leur guérilla contre l'État comme à
chaque fois ils ont cassé tabassé
incendié et agresser nos forces de
l'ordre selon un scénario aujourd'hui
bien connu il y avait même parmi eux un
fichier s monsieur le ministre vous
savez pertinemment qui ils sont où ils
habitent quels sont leurs modes d'action
vous avez toutes les clés en main pour
les empêcher de nuit et pourtant ils
sont libres et continuent à semer le
chaos peut-être cette violence de
l'ultra gauche vous permettait au
passage de détourner l'attention de la
politique du gouvernement mais en
attendant pas le mal à la racine vous
laissez prospérer la mauvaise herbe
c'est ultra gauche haineuse est toujours
plus armée toujours plus violente mieux
organisée et désormais internationalisés
elle communique en toute liberté sur les
réseaux sociaux et elle recrute ce sont
de véritables milices armés qui sont en
formation dans notre pays contre notre
pays depuis des années nous alertons
avec Marine Le Pen contre l'escalade de
cette mouvance si nous n'y prenons garde
à ce rythme là nous vivrons peut-être
bientôt sous la menace de nouvelles
années de plomb dans cet escalade de la
violence nous risquons de voir
apparaître les successeurs des Brigades
rouges ou d'action direct avec cette
fois comme prétexte la protection de
l'environnement la bascule dans une
forme décor ou terrorisme impliquerait
un risque d'attaque sur des
infrastructures vitales ou sensibles
avec pour corollaire la mise en danger
de vie humaine alors agissez monsieur le
ministre et agissez vite pouvez-vous
nous dire ici quelles sont les mesures
que vous comptez mettre en place pour
éradiquer ces milices d'extrême gauche
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et ministre des Outre-mer
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
de la comédie je vais évidemment
répondre à votre question je regrette
qu'en propose l'iminaire vous n'avez pas
eu un mot pour les policiers les
gendarmes blessés
ces derniers jours
je constate d'ailleurs qu'avant les
événements de sainte Soline vos prises
de parole publique ont été assez
défavorables pour pas dire très
défavorable contre la police sur les
plateaux de télévision et je serai prêt
à vous donner quelques extraits et je
vous encourage à ne pas soutenir la
police quand ça vous arrange il y a chez
les policiers et chez les gendarmes des
femmes et des hommes de toute opinion
politique qui nous protègent n'ayez pas
le soutien à la police s'il vous plaît
sélectif et vous avez raison
vous avez raison monsieur le député il y
a Quevilly il y a des militants
extrémistes dans notre pays il y en a
beaucoup de l'ultra gauche il y en a
beaucoup de ultra droites nous aimerions
aussi que vous les condamniez de la même
manière il y a des personnes qui sont
fichées dans d'autres pays vous avez
raison mais je vais vous rappeler ici
Monsieur député qu'un fichier de
renseignements n'est pas une accrémation
pénale et d'ailleurs je constate que le
gouvernement lorsqu'il y avait un autre
ministre d'intérieur que vous avez
combattu alors qu'il avait été courageux
donc contre cette question Monsieur
Christophe Castaner a été censuré à
l'époque par le Conseil constitutionnel
et vous n'avez pas voté le texte qu'il
vous avait proposé
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mon cher collègue
je n'aurais donc pas de réponse
j'aimerais que vous ayez monsieur le
ministre la même virulence quand il
s'agit d'attaquer ces milices d'extrême
gauche que quand vous attaquez
l'opposition parlementaire et
démocratique merci beaucoup
je te remercie monsieur le ministre
je pense que vous avez fait une sorte de
lapsus intellectuel je n'ai pas parlé du
rassemblement national quand je parle
ultra droite si vous sentiez visé j'en
suis désolé
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur
Éric Ciotti pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre depuis plusieurs semaines des
millions de Français manifestent
calmement encadré de façon responsable
par les organisations syndicales
malheureusement dans ces cortèges ce
sont glissés des militants d'extrême
gauche dont le seul objectif et de
piller de brûler de tuer du flic dans ce
contexte nos policiers nos gendarmes se
trouvent en première ligne plus de 500
d'entre eux ont été blessés à l'occasion
de la manifestation de jeudi dernier ou
samedi à Sainte solide 500 policiers aux
gendarmes qui garantissent l'ordre
républicain nous leur devons une
reconnaissance nous leur devons un
hommage républicain pour leur dire que
sans eux la République ne tiendrait pas
les policiers mais sans surprise
constateront que sur les bancs de
l'extrême gauche cet hommage n'est pas
accepté et vous refusez de vous y
associer comme Madame panot ce matin
indiqué de façon scandaleuse comme
manifestant était mort instrumentalisant
ce conflit social à des visées
extrémistes alors oui je le dis nous
demandons dans ce contexte des mesures
fortes le ministre de l'Intérieur vient
d'en parler mais cela ne suffit pas les
mots ne suffisent plus il faut des actes
il faut des actes concrets ces individus
ces milistent extrêmes d'Oches sont
connus il faut aujourd'hui les éradiquer
il faut changer de cadre je veux
également dénoncer avec force les propos
honteux de Monsieur Mélenchon appelant à
faire soigner les policiers sans doute
sans doute dans les camps de rééducation
qui existent dans les pays dictator
je vous demande monsieur le ministre
madame la Première ministre si vous
envisagez de
vous merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président merci pour les mots que vous
avez eu pour les policiers pour les
gendarmes je veux aussi penser aux
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été pris à
parti encore ce matin d'ailleurs dans
l'ouest de la France
je veux souligner monsieur le député
cioti que les préfets de la République
les policiers et les gendarmes et les
organisations syndicales ont su
organiser oui grandes journées de
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites sans qu'il n'y ait aucun
incident majeur de notre pays avec des
millions de personnes vous le savez bien
partout sur le territoire national et je
veux
des millions cumulés madame la présente
Le Pen ne vous inquiétez pas
ce qui est important de souligner c'est
que lorsque l'extrême gauche est l'ultra
gauche c'est mener depuis le 16 mars
dernier
aux manifestations sauvages non déclarés
s'attaquant au carré syndicaux
s'attaquant aux policiers aux gendarmes
s'attaquant des préfectures à des
commissariats à des hôpitaux à des
tribunaux à des permanences politiques
et des parlementaires menaçants les îles
de la République alors oui oui le chaos
cherche à s'installer est-ce que je
regrette comme vous monsieur ci c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas uneanimité dans la
classe politique pour dénoncer ces
groupes factieux qui veulent mettre à
bas la République parce que l'ultra
gauche ne veut pas attaquer la réforme
des retraites elle va attaquer la
République
ultra gauche ne veut pas attaquer le
gouvernement elle veut attaquer les
policiers et ça fait 8 groupuscules ou
associations d'extrême gauche que je
propose à la dissolution toute validé
par le Conseil d'État nous continuerons
grâce au service de renseignement et
j'espère avec une indemnité de la
présentation nationale
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur François
Jolivet pour le groupe horizon merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le groupe
horizon tient d'abord et avant tout à
rendre un hommage au nom de la
représentation nationale au gendarmes
Arnaud blanc papa de deux enfants et qui
a été tué dans une opération de luttre
contre leur paillage illégal ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'intérieur des
Outre-mer
441 c'est le nombre de policiers
gendarmes qui ont été blessés en France
lors des manifestations de ces dernières
semaines à cela s'ajoutent les 47
gendarmes blessés les week-end dernier
lors de l'opération de sécurisation et
de maintien de l'ordre d'une
manifestation interdite à Sainte-Soline
je ne peux pas ne pas penser non plus
aux deux manifestants qui aujourd'hui
luttent pour leur vie et dont aucun ne
sont décédés aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues les forces de l'ordre exercent
leur mission celles d'assurer la
sécurité des personnes et des biens je
tiens à saluer l'engagement de ces
femmes et de ses hommes qui consacrent
leur vie professionnelle et trop souvent
une partie de leur vie personnelle à
l'intérêt général à protection de leurs
concitoyens de nos de leurs concitoyens
de nous en fait soyez assurés du soutien
plané entier du groupe horizon et à
parenté à toutes les forces de l'ordre
loin de moi l'idée de mettre sur la même
plan des manifestations organisées et
sécurisées en grande responsabilité par
les organisations syndicales d'un côté
et l'émergence de groupes de casseurs
d'extrémistes et de autres Black Blocs
et tout autre personne ressemblante de
l'autre venue pour générer de la
violence contre nos institutions et la
représentants à Paris comme ailleurs des
manifestations se transforment voire
même tombent dans l'illégalité absence
de déclaration préalable en préfecture
absence d'itinérée après défini absence
de service d'ordre tout contribue à une
escalade de violence illégitime
incomprise par les Français et porteuses
d'un seul message la conflictualisation
de notre société monsieur mise de
l'Intérieur mes questions sont les
suivantes comment assurer dans ces
conditions une politique de maintien de
l'ordre adapté qui concilie justement
liberté de manifester et sécurité des
personnes et des biens de quels moyens
le ministre de l'Intérieur dispose-t-il
pour empêcher que des manifestations
pacifistes soient polluées par une
frange d'extrémiste merci la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Jolivet je
veux également vous remercier comme
certains de vos collègues l'ont fait
pour le soutien que vous apportez aux
forces de l'ordre je veux dire bien
évidemment qu'en ce qui concerne sainte
Soline le gouvernement de la République
n'a rien à cacher et j'ai donc demandé
deux rapports le premier à la préfète
des Deux-Sèvres le deuxième le directeur
général de la gendarmerie rapports qui
ont été élaborés jusqu'à ce matin et je
les mettrai en ligne cet après-midi sur
le site du ministère de l'Intérieur et
je l'ai dit au président de la
commission des lois des deux assemblées
je suis à la disposition de toutes et
tous pour moi-même ainsi que ceux qui
ont eu en commandement à répondre aux
interrogations de la présentation
nationale je veux par ailleurs dire que
lors de ces manifestations évidemment le
devoir je parle des manifestations
déclarées pas celles qui sont interdites
le devoir des policiers et des gendarmes
et de permettre aux gens de manifester
bien évidemment c'est le premier honneur
des policiers et des gendarmes et ils le
font je crois de façon répétée dans
toutes les villes de France avec calme
et avec dignité je veux d'ailleurs dire
ici que la confiance absolue et le
soutien total que j'ai envers les forces
de l'ordre depuis quasiment 3 ans que je
suis mis à l'intérieur n'empêche pas
évidemment d'avoir la même exigence dans
le respect de la déontologie et que s'il
devait y avoir des policiers et des
gendarmes qui ne respectent pas le droit
ils sont évidemment sanctionnés je veux
dire monsieur le député que il nous
manque pour répondre totalement à votre
question trois choses la première c'est
de plus en première pardon c'est de plus
en plus de force de l'ordre
singulièrement des unités de force
mobile puisque l'ordre public c'est un
métier ce n'est pas la police judiciaire
ce n'est pas la sécurité publique vous
nous l'avez accordé par la loi de
programmation très largement votée ici
dans cette hémicycle quelque chose merci
la deuxième des choses c'est évidemment
des images pour des raisons évidemment
complexes que vous avez suivi la police
la gendarmerie sont les seuls à ne pas
sont les seuls à ne pas pouvoir faire
voler des drones en France bientôt le
décret qui sortira de la loi sécurité
globale qui est à la CNIL et maintenant
Conseil d'État permettra à la police
gendarmerie d'avoir des drones quand les
casseurs en ont eu à Sainte Soline voilà
la vérité qu'on doit dire aux Français
et troisièmement c'est évidemment de
continuer à notre attaque contre
l'extrême gauche c'est ce que je pense
au sens de ma réponse au présidentiotti
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Clémentine au
thym pour le groupe LFI
la première ministre combien de temps
combien de temps encore allez-vous
écraser la démocratie de tout le poids
de vos 49-3 de tout le choc de vos
matraques de tout le mépris d'une
poignée qui décide enfermé dans son
monde nous avons fait la réforme des
retraites que les Français attendaient
avez-vous osé affirmer ce week-end
devant les quelques amis qu'il vous
reste vous prétendez vouloir apaiser
vous alimentez chaque jour davantage le
chaudron de la colère vous vous prenez
pour le sac le de la raison vous n'êtes
que des raisons vous vous croyez dans
votre bon droit vous jouez d'une
confusion entre la légalité et la
démocratie ce que les Français attendent
madame la Première ministre et vous le
savez c'est le retrait de votre projet
les organisations syndicales
exemplairement unique entre vous l'exige
depuis des mois cette Français sur dix
n'en veulent pas 90% des salariés le
rejettent en rage devant la brutalité de
votre méthode les Français vous le
disent sur tous les tons et aujourd'hui
dixième journée de mobilisation
nationale il défile à nouveau en masse
dans tout le pays ils font grève ils
bloque il pétitionne mais devant un tel
déferlement que nous n'avons pas connu
depuis
1968 mes chers collègues et bien
visiblement le gouvernement le président
de la République ont perdu toute
connexion au monde réel et toute
humanité devant le Christ sourd du pays
que vous enchaînez
alors
qui est de régler un désordre que vous
avez créé c'est dangereux pour les
citoyennes et les citoyens c'est
foudroyants pour la démocratie mais
votre stratégie du pourrissement de
l'intimidation de la tension permanente
et accélérée ne cesse d'échouer elle
échoue parce que notre pays renoue avec
une histoire que vous méprisez celle de
l’irruption de ceux qui ne sont rien
celle de la foule qui se sépare merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée au temps
madame la députée
madame la députée alimenter le chaudron
de la colère opposé la légitimité de la
rue à celle de la démocratie
parlementaire il aurait suffi que vous
ajoutiez bloquez le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée par l'obstruction et c'est
votre acte d'accusation que vous aviez
dressé en réalité votre question votre
interpellation madame la députée c'est
l'accusation négative de ce que vous
faites de ce que vous souhaitez de ce
que vous nourrissez vous nous dites
retirer la réforme dites-le aux femmes à
qui nous allons relever les pensions
dites-le aux salariés qui sont exposés
au métier les plus pénibles et pour
lesquels nous allons améliorer la prise
en compte de la pénibilité et permettre
des départs facilités dites-le à toutes
les femmes et je sais que c'est un sujet
qui vous tient à cœur pour lesquels nous
allons faire en sorte d'intégrer des
trimestres de congés parental d'imprimer
des trimestres passés à aider leurs
proches lorsqu'elles sont aidantes dans
les trimestres qui à la fois pour
accéder à minimum de pension mais aussi
à des dispositifs de carrière anticipées
dites-le un million 800 000 retraités
qui vont voir leur pension de retraite
être augmenté au mois de septembre
madame la députée en réalité car vous
dites retirer la réforme vous voulez
enlever ses droits aux Français vous
vous le vendez vous voulez enlever les
dispositifs qui vont bénéficier au plus
fragile de celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent votre politique mesdames les
députés est une politique antisociale
votre objectif est un objectif de chaos
et en réalité vous ne souhaitez qu'une
chose je voulais dire c'est que la
misère prospère parce que sur la misère
c'est vous qui prospérez
je
je vous remercie pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre et je m'adresse au
nom du groupe liotte madame la Première
ministre vous dites vouloir apaiser et
pourtant vous ne faites aucun geste
aucun pas vers ceux qui vous tendent la
main le président de la République a
évoqué la semaine dernière une colère
légitime et pourtant il est resté
prostré dans son arrogance les Français
l'intersyndical les manifestants les
oppositions ne vous demandent qu'une
chose suspendre ou retirée choisissez le
terme que vous voulez cette réforme
depuis l'utilisation
improvisée du 49.3 les escalade de la
tension sociale et palpable partout dans
le pays entre les manifestants méprisés
les forces de l'ordre épuisées les gros
violents galvanisés les violences sont
de plus en plus nombreuses nous
condamnons avec la plus grande fermeté
celle-ci dans ce désordre le
gouvernement a une responsabilité non
négligeable
madame la Première ministre il faut que
cela cesse il faut que cela s'arrête
vous ne pouvez pas vous ne devez pas
faire le choix du pourrissement par
tactique politicienne nous voulons le
retour à la paix le retour au calme
madame la Première ministre avec
humilité
saisissez la main de ce qui prône le
dialogue le respect et le compromis
suspendait cette réforme
je vous remercie la c'est un monsieur
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail de
l'insertion et du plein emploi merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le député de
Saint-Huile je ne reviendrai pas sur la
totalité du débat vous le savez
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat ont
débattu pendant 175 heures de la réforme
des retraites et après de celui-ci que
celle-ci pardon était l'objet de 4 mois
de concertation 4 mois à l'issue
desquels avec madame la Première
ministre nous avons présenté un texte
qui avait été considérablement enrichi
et amélioré le débat parlementaire a
permis d'améliorer encore le texte il a
permis de l'améliorer avec une meilleure
prise dans le compte des carrières
longues il imprime permis de l'améliorer
en protégeant mieux les femmes qui ont
une carrière complète à 63 ans avec la
possibilité d'une circotte il a permis
de l'améliorer avec la prise en compte
améliorée des trimestres d'apprentissage
la possibilité de racheter plus
facilement des trimestres de stage ou
d'études supérieures le texte tel qu'il
a été adopté monsieur le député n'est
plus véritablement le texte du
Gouvernement il répond à nos objectifs
mais c'est avant tout le texte du
Parlement tel qu'il a été adopté par la
commission mixte paritaire aujourd'hui
ce texte va être mis en oeuvre et vous
nous appelez à le suspender il n'est pas
possible de suspendre un texte tel qu'il
a été voté vous nous appelez à reprendre
le dialogue la première ministre pas
plus tard qu'il y a quelques instants à
un nouveau proposé à l'intersydical de
la rencontre de discuter d'évoquer les
questions d'usure professionnelle dès
que d'évoquer les questions relatives au
déroulement des carrières de faire en
sorte que tous les sujets liés au
travail et que nous reprendrons dans le
cadre d'un futur projet de loi puisse
être amélioré la volonté de débat est là
et nous avons cette volonté de débat en
faisant bien la différence entre les
organisations syndicales avec lesquels
nous souhaitons discuter et les
émeutiers les factieux qui veulent
mettre du désordre et que nous ne
confondons pas avec les partenaires
sociaux je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur Saint-Huile
madame la Première ministre vous êtes
une femme d'état vous savez la
responsabilité qui est la vôtre madame
la Première ministre il n'y a pas de
déshonneur à reconnaître une erreur il
n'y a pas de défaite à reconnaître un
échec la seule chose qui doit nous
guider c'est l'intérêt de la nation
l'intérêt des Françaises et des Français
en sagesse pour permettre le retour d'un
débat serein pour permettre le dialogue
avec tout le monde à la table retirer
cette réforme dès à présent
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie reiste
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention début avril devrait
s'appliquer la loi que nous avons voté
en 2021 qui portait la mesure 3 du Ségur
permettant de limiter l'intérim médical
excessif il ne s'agit pas ici
d'interdire l'intérim médical mais bien
dans limiter le recours de façon
démesurée qui peut parfois dépasser les
4000 euros par jour en faisant respecter
un plafond légal fixé depuis 2016 à 1170
euros par jour ces pratiques
déstructures les activités hospitalières
rendent les situations inéquitables
écoute plus de 1 milliard 5 d'euros à
l'Assurance Maladie comment certains
médecins hospitaliers peuvent tolérer
qu'un intérimaire moi engagé pour
l'établissement gagne parfois à son
salaire mensuel en deux ou trois jours
c'est pour cette raison que
l'application de la loi est soutenue par
les fédérations hospitalières les
directeurs d'établissements les
présidentes commissions médicales même
si en tant qu’élu je suis nous sommes
convaincus de la nécessité de
l'application de la loi je veux ici me
faire le relais de nos inquiétudes face
à la menace de fermeture de certains
services des hôpitaux de nos régions par
exemple la Loire de notre collègue
bataillon la préservation de notre
hôpital public est un enjeu majeur pour
nous tous nous devons le rendre plus
attractif nous avons avec le Ségur
apporter une première réponse mais nous
devons je crois mieux valoriser les
professionnels engagés pour leur
établissement au bénéfice des patients
comment notamment valoriser mieux les
professionnels qui travaillent la nuit
et le week-end monsieur le ministre
l'application de cette loi a été
retardée car elle nécessite un travail
en amont pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de risque pour nos concitoyens
et que le mesure soit appliquée de façon
identique partout en France pouvez-vous
alors de confirmer ici que la mise en
place de cette loi peut se faire en
toute sécurité pour nos concitoyens je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur François Braun ministre
de la Santé de la prévention merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame députés
Stéphanie risque j'entends bien sûr les
inquiétudes qui montent des différents
territoires sur la mise en application
de cette loi pour autant il est
totalement indispensable de mettre en
application cette loi qui touche vous
l'avez très bien dit non pas l'intérim
médical qui est très utile dans nos
hôpitaux mais c'est intérim mercenaire
qui dérive complètement depuis trois ans
avec des tarifs qui atteignent 5000
euros pour 24 heures de garde ce qui est
tout à fait inacceptable mais aussi le
nombre qui augmente avec plus de 80%
d'augmentation ces deux dernières années
pourquoi maintenant parce que c'est en
train de détruire notre système
hospitalier public c'est en train de
faire partir les médecins de l'hôpital
public qui comme vous l'avez très bien
dit voit un praticien gagné en une nuit
ou en ce que eux gagnent en un mois
c'est donc une nécessité absolue et
d'agir rapidement pour agir je tiens
avec les ARS un compte extrêmement
précis depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
de tous les services qui sont concernés
de nombreuses solutions ont été trouvées
j'étais encore hier à Alençon où ils ont
trouvé des solutions territoriales c'est
une des solutions pour avancer dans la
réforme de notre système de santé avec
des gros hôpitaux des CHU qui viennent
en soutien de ces établissements pour
maintenir les lignes de garde il faut
agir sur les deux tableaux combattre cet
intérim cannibale mais également
revaloriser le statut les conditions de
travail des médecins hospitaliers c'est
ce que je suis en train de faire c'est
ce que j'ai annoncé avec la
revalorisation de la prime de solidarité
territoriale c'est également la reprise
de discussion avec les représentants des
syndicats pour aménor améliorer en
particulier la pénibilité et travailler
sur la pénibilité
chaque territoire nous lui proposerons
une solution tous les jours les choses
évoluent tous les jours des solutions
sont trouvées jusqu'au dernier moment
les ARS et mon ministère seront à côté
des établissements pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de lacunes dans la prise en charge
de nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Florence Goulet pour
le rassemblement national
présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances à se tenait comme une de
moins de 3000 habitants de ma
circonscription du Nord le groupe
finlandais Alström première de ce
territoire a annoncé son intention de
fermer son usine pasetière s'ils ne
trouve pas de repreneur
130 salariés sont concernés autant de
familles sans compter les emplois
indirects situation dramatique dans un
bassin où l'attractivité déjà en
souffrance et qui offre peu de solutions
de reclassement dans cette usine 77
employés ont déjà fait l'objet d'un plan
social en 2019 sous prétexte de
permettre au groupe d'investir dans
l'outil de production pourtant
trahissant la confiance et l'espoir des
salariés ces investissements n'ont pas
eu lieu et cette usine subit aujourd'hui
de plein fouet la concurrence dans un
contexte de crise énergétique sans
précédent
la Meuse est un département déjà très
éprouvé gris pavières multiplication de
fermetures de petits commerces dont 11
boulangeries qui en raison de votre
obstination à ne pas vouloir sortir du
marché européen de l'électricité ont du
cessé leur activité et nous venons
d'apprendre que Petit Colin la plus
ancienne et dernière fabrique de poupées
va fermer son atelier créé en 1860 a
éteint toujours dans ma circonscription
dans le même temps ce gouvernement
supprime des services publics pourtant
indispensable par exemple ce n'est pas
moi de 18 classes qui seront fermées à
la prochaine rentrée scolaire
hélas monsieur le ministre lorsque l'on
se retrouve au chômage dans la Meuse il
ne suffit pas de traverser la rue pour
retrouver un emploi monsieur le ministre
il y a un an vous déclariez que
l'industrie française se portait bien la
semaine dernière le président Macron se
vantait encore de ce qu'il y aurait eu
plus d'entreprises ouvertes que fermées
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir les 130
salariés d'alstrom eupennent à discerner
les raisons de cet enthousiasme
peut-être voyez-vous la situation d'un
peu trop haut peut-être voyez-vous les
choses d'un peu trop loin peut-être
qu'un voyage en me s'impose pour
appréter la priorité chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Goulet d'abord je note avec satisfaction
qu'une députée qui se qualifiait
elle-même de parachuter assumer il y a
quelques mois s'intéresse aux
entreprises de son territoire
madame la députée
[Musique]
du coup
nous n'avons pas attendu je vous cite
madame la députée je vous cite madame la
députée nous n'avons pas attendu votre
parachute à puisque c'est comme ça que
vous vous qualifiez pour nous occuper de
l'industrie française
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît on écoute la réponse du
ministre monsieur le ministre
depuis maintenant plus de 5 ans madame
la députée depuis maintenant plus de 5
ans ce gouvernement s'est a tué à la
réindustrialisation de la France et ne
vous en déplaît puisque vous vous
nourrissez de la désindustrialisation
depuis 25 ans nous sommes sur la bonne
voie nous avons créé 90 000 emplois nous
avons ouvert l'année dernière plus
d'usines que nous n'en avons fermé 170
ouvertures pour 50 fermetures soladim
madame la députée malheureusement des
usines ferment en France ça arrive et ça
arrive vous l'avez dit dans votre
circonscription et comme toutes les
usines qui ferment en France nous sommes
aux côtés des salariés et des
territoires quel que soit d'ailleurs la
couleur des députés en question
et pour cette entreprise pour cette
usine de notre zone astrum comme pour
toutes les autres nous rencontrons la
direction mon équipe la fière nous
organis nous rencontrons les
organisations dans un syndical dans des
plaisent à celles et ceux qui penseront
que nous nous les organisations
syndicales qui n'en déplaisent à celles
et ceux qui pensent que nous n'aimons
pas le dialecte social et nous
accompagnons les salariés nous
accompagnons l'entreprise pour trouver
un repreneur et j'espère que nous le
ferons nous serons prêts comme
d'habitude à accompagner le repreneur
dans cette dans cette opération madame
la députée nous croyons l'industrie
française vous vous nourrissez de son
déclin nous sommes d'accord là dessus
pour ne pas être d'accord merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
Coulomme pour le groupe la France
insoumise
Conseil de l'Europe Ligue des droits de
l'Homme Défenseur des droits Amnesty
International le Parlement belge
jusqu'au finals tous les observateurs de
ce cauchemar que vous avez provoqué
dénonce le sinistre théâtre que vous
mettez en scène au prétexte mensongé de
faire le bonheur des Français contre
leur gré une police qui roule à moto sur
un manifestant à terre qui matraque les
crânes qui gaz à bout portant une député
un écharpe la bravème qui tire sur une
mer de famille et lui détruit la main
qui tire sur un syndicaliste et lui
arrache un œil qui violente sexuellement
des femmes nacées qui dégoupillent 4000
grenades au TNT à la face de nos jeunes
révoltés par votre corruption et
considère des comas et après monsieur
Darmanin l'agresseur n'est pas l'arme
mais celui qui l'actionne et vous êtes
déjà allé trop loin avec notre police
que vous tenez pour votre arme de
répression brutale
nos policiers ne sont pas engagés pour
être vos instruments du matraquage de
tout un peuple qui conteste votre coup
de force et la justice sur injonction de
son ministre elle est sommée d'infliger
une réponse pénale rapide se mettant
ainsi au service d'interpellation et de
garde à vue arbitraire pour dissuader
mais dont les victimes ressortent
majoritairement exemples de motifs de
poursuite pénaliser nos libertés
d'expression de circuler de manifester
de faire grève mais légaliser les
réquisitions violentes le travail forcé
et la dispersion des piquets de grève du
cachot et après monsieur Dupont-Moretti
répression policière et répression
judiciaire sont les deux pies de cette
macronie de réforme argument ultime d'un
forfait capricieux quand allez-vous
cesser d'infiger votre sanglante une
recette du bonheur à tout un peuple qui
n'en veut pas quand allez-vous cesser de
faire ce confronter policier et
manifestants les mettant les uns comme
les autres en danger mortel quant
allez-vous cesser d'abîmer notre pays en
dévoyant ses gardiens de la paix ces
magistrats ces institutions ça
constitution au profit de la clique de
profiteurs qui seul aura joui de votre
politique
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministres de la justice
madame madame la présidente madame
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
il y a de ça quelques mois quelques
années
c'était après le Bataclan on voulait
embrasser les flics aujourd'hui vous
vomissez dessus voilà voilà la réalité
je veux ici rappeler que Monsieur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon votre leader maximo a
été condamné définitivement pour avoir
exercé des violences sur des policiers
et sur un procureur de la République
voilà Monsieur le Député la réalité
je vais maintenant vous dire que par les
temps troublés que nous traversons je
vous suggère d'avoir apporté de main la
constitution et le code de procédure
pénale dans la Constitution vous lirez
que nous ne sommes affranchis d'aucune
règle démocratique et dans le code de
procédure pénale vous pourrez lire par
exemple que les gardes à vue que vous
fustigez sont en réalité une mesure
coercitive prise par un officier de
police judiciaire sous le contrôle d'un
procureur chaque fois qu'il y a une
raison plausible de suspecter qu'une
infraction a été commise c'est pas plus
compliqué que cela Monsieur le Député
voyez-vous et ensuite la justice vient
faire son travail la garde à vue s'est
raison plausibles la mise en examen
c'est indice grave et concordant le
renvoie devant le tribunal ce sont des
charges et enfin la condamnation ce sont
des preuves si vous n'êtes pas convaincu
je vous suggère ce week-end une balade à
la campagne mais sans essence sans
cagoule sans h sans cocktail Molotov
rendez-vous est pris
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
que le peuple français ne veut de votre
loi scélérate redevez des lignes retirez
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
turquois pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer au nom du groupe démocrate
je tiens à exprimer tout d'abord notre
soutien total aux habitants et aux
agriculteurs des environs de
Sainte-Soline et à leurs proches
de depuis des semaines ils vivent un
quotidien fait de harcèlement et
d'intimidation il redoute que leurs
propres enfants ou leurs parents âgés
soient des victimes collatérales
d'action de sabotage et ce week-end ils
ont vécu l'enfer je veux ensuite rendre
un hommage appuyé à tous ces gendarmes
et à ses pompiers qui ont tout
simplement servi au péril de leur vie
cette manif
cette manifestation jugée dangereuse et
violente était interdite elle a dépassé
tous les qualificatifs et son bilan est
dramatique nous condamnons en revanche
avec force l'attitude d'élus de la
République qui ont participé à cet
événement interdit ou qui ont parlé
d'une déambulance Sion déambulation
joyeuse et festive alors que dès le
vendredi 150 individus masqués armés ont
investi les voies de la ligne à grande
vitesse à proximité et que le samedi des
centaines de Black Blocs ont attaqué les
forces de l'ordre un coup de pierre de
boules de pétanque de mortier ou de
cocktail Molotov le combat des idées
légitimes il peut même être rude mais
aucune incitation ou même compréhension
de la violence n'est acceptable en
démocratie
il nous faut pas dénoncer ces gros
muscles d'extrême gauche qui sous des
noms poétiques organisent et planifient
ces déchaînements de violence sous
couvert d'une cause écologiste mais qui
au final ont pour seul objectif de
mettre de mettre la France à feu et à
100 monsieur le ministre la République
ne peut tolérer de tels déferlement de
violence
face à l'ampleur de ce qui s'est passé
ce week-end que comptez-vous faire pour
qu'aucun agriculteur et sa famille en
Deux-Sèvres ou ailleurs en France ne
revivent un jour comme celui-ci je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
turquoise je veux évidemment comme la
fée le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc
féno que l'a fait également Christophe
Béchu dire tout notre soutien aux
agriculteurs français à leur outil de
travail
alors bien
évidemment à leur famille
savez-vous monsieur le député que lors
des événements dramatiques de sainte
Soline beaucoup d'entre eux ont été
menacés qu'ils ont dû quitter leur ferme
laisser ainsi leur bétail et leur outil
de production pour éviter justement de
connaître des menaces physiques combien
combien
ont-ils reçu de menaces la protection
policière est des gendarmes et complètes
notamment dans cette partie de l'Ouest
de la France pour les protéger contre
toutes les menaces et non aucune ZAD ne
s'est installé à Sainte Soline ni il y a
6 mois ni le week-end dernier et oui
sainte Soline c'est ce sont des bassines
quel que soit de ce qu'on en pense qui
ont été discutés avec des professionnels
valider par les élus y compris ce qui
combattent le gouvernement et je
voudrais en souligner ici qu'elles ont
été aussi validées par la justice et que
non nous ne laisserons pas faire des
militants d'ultra gauche radicalisés
menaçant son prenant directement aux
agriculteurs parce que derrière les
bassines il ne s'agit pas simplement
d'un endroit où on met de l'eau mais il
s'agit de la vie de milliers de
personnes qui savent tôt le matin qui se
couchent tard le soir et qui sont
menacés chaque jour par des personnes
radicales
qui nourrissent les Français et qui
méritent notre respect plutôt que les
insultes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Sophie tailler
polluant du groupe écologiste
merci
pas le chronomètre merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
premier flic de France
hier lors de votre conférence de presse
vous avez longuement détaillé le
déploiement d'un gigantesque
dispositif d'agents de police et de
gendarmerie en prévision des
manifestations d'aujourd'hui à chaque
mobilisation finalement c'est l'escalade
pensez-vous réellement pouvoir demander
aux forces de l'ordre de résoudre la
crise politique majeure qui traverse
notre pays quasiment une crise de régime
par la faute du gouvernement auquel vous
appartenait par la faune du président de
la République qui de plus en plus isolé
dans son château s'obstine a essayé de
faire passer par la force une réforme
qui n'a pas pu faire passer par le vote
pensez-vous que ce soit le travail des
forces de l'ordre nous ne le pensons pas
par vos décisions vous mettez en danger
les citoyens qui manifestent mais aussi
les forces de l'ordre et de manière je
le crois totalement injustifié
à ce jour pas moins de 17 enquêtes ont
été ouvertes à l'IGPN sans compter les
arrestations préventives les coups de
matraques reçus par des manifestants et
parfois par de simples passants par vos
voltigeurs deux personnes sont dans le
coma depuis ce week-end des jeunes
femmes ont été victimes d'agressions
sexuelles à Nantes des milliers de
grenades de désencerclement de gaz
lacrymo étaient lancés à l'aveugle bref
l'escalade ces violences elles sont
aujourd'hui documentées filmées visibles
on ne peut pas continuer de les ignorer
il semble que vous cherchiez à attiser
les tensions afin d'incarner l'ordre et
de sortir de cette crise par le recours
à l'autorité vous instrumentalisez ainsi
les agents de police alors vous devez en
sortir par la raison c'est à dire par
leur retrait de la réforme des retraites
par ce geste d'apaisement demandé par
l'Inter syndical alors Monsieur Darmanin
quand allez-vous arrêter d'être le
premier flic de France pour devenir
ministre de l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire au
service de l'intérêt général et de la
démocratie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés mais le député
permettez-moi tout d'abord de vous dire
que je ne suis pas le premier fils de
France parce que je n'ai pas le courage
ni vous d'ailleurs d'être à la place des
policiers qui chaque jour risquent leur
vie pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
vous me demandez madame la députée que
s'est-il passé madame
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous me demandez madame la députée que
s'est-il passé moi je vous pose la
question que s'est-il passé à gauche
pour qu'on confondeur et policier que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on n'est
pas un mot dans une question d'actualité
pour penser à tous ces policiers ces
gendarmes qui sont blessés
que s'est-il passé à gauche quand on a
pas un mot quand on attaque des
commissariats des tribunaux des
préfectures des permanences de
parlementaires que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour qu'on confond manifestation
interdite et manifestation autorisées
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
ne respecte plus l'uniforme de la
République que s'est-il passé à gauche
madame la députée pour qu'on oublie à ce
point
Clémenceau Chevènement Cazeneuve Valls
Mitterrand Badinter
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
aisse des policiers que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour faire alliance avec Monsieur
Mélenchon qui les insultent qu'il est
vomit et qui finalement fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche
elle a du temps quoi
je n'ai insulté personne monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
aux policiers et aux gendarmes que vous
blesser chaque jour vous devriez
présenter vos excuses à l'uniforme de la
République sur lequel vous crachez et
vous devriez présenter vos excuses
d'attisées par la colère ce que vous
n'avez pas eu par les urnes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Christine pires
bonne pour le groupe socialiste
madame la Première ministre vous n'avez
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
d'où le 49.3 vous n'avez pas de majorité
dans le pays d'où le refus du référendum
vous n'avez pas de perspective politique
d'où votre appel au syndicat à parler de
tout sauf des retraites avez-vous
seulement conscience de ce qui se passe
dans le pays on peut en douter quand on
entend vos propos hallucinant sur votre
prétendu victoire ou avoir fait ce que
les Français attendaient ou ceux du
ministre du socle sur la volonté de
désordre qui existerait dans les
cortèges de manifestants alors qu'il n'y
a rien de plus faux écoutez-les les
cortèges ils parlent démocratie respect
du travail et des travailleurs ces
postures c'est caricatures vous
éloignent chaque jour un peu plus du
peuple madame la Première ministre notre
pays a besoin d'apaisement vous voulez
un nouveau départ mais il n'y aura pas
de nouveau départ ni avec les groupes
parlementaires ni avec les partenaires
sociaux tant que la loi retraite n'aura
pas été remisée alors madame la Première
ministre cesser la vous n'engendrez pas
la réforme des retraites elle va vous
suivre comme le sparadra du capitaine
Haddock vous ne changerez pas de
séquence à votre gré le peuple et
l'assemblée vont dicter leur ordre du
jour et celui-ci appelle des mesures en
faveur de l'hôpital public en faveur de
nos aînés dans les EHPAD en faveur des
Français confrontés à l'inflation en
faveur des territoires oubliés vous
voulez gouverner alors écoutez
l'Assemblée nationale écouter le peuple
écoutez la démocratie la démocratie
c'est le respect du pouvoir législatif
pas son enjambement la démocratie c'est
l'écoute de l'expression du peuple
notamment par la manifestation qui est
le cœur battant de la démocratie et le
peuple madame la Première ministre ce
n'est pas la foule même s'il y a
effectivement foule dans la rue Madame
la première ministre voulait sortir de
votre isolement vous voulez trouver des
majorités à l'Assemblée ce ne sera pas
simple mais il y a un préalable un
préalable pas attendu par beaucoup y
compris par certains dans votre majorité
ce préalable c'est le retrait de la
réforme des retraites il est concrète
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée puisse bonne
vous nous appelez à retirer la réforme
et vous nous appelez à respecter
l'expression
du peuple l'expression la démocratie ou
l'expression du Parlement le premier
respect c'est le respect du résultat des
urnes le président de la République a
fait campagne avec un engagement réformé
le système de retraite l'ensemble des
députés de la majorité a fait campagne
avec un engagement réformé le système de
retraite cette réforme a été conduite
dans la concertation cette réforme a été
conduite avec 175 heures au débat de
débat au Parlement et c'est grâce à
cette majorité que des améliorations
étaient apportées pour les carrières
longues pour la pénibilité avec
l'ensemble des mesures correctrices qui
ont été intégrées au texte non pas grâce
à vous mais grâce au travail de la
majorité parlementaire et de la majorité
présidentielle vous nous dites madame la
députée il n'y a pas de majorité je vous
rejoins sur un point il n'y a pas de
majorité alternative et le rejet
d'émotions de sang sur la montrer le
véritable échec madame la député c'est
celui de la nupaisse vous n'avez pas
bougé une ligne du texte vous n'avez pas
gagné un vote vous n'avez pas empêché
son adoption vous êtes en réalité en
échec parce que votre stratégie est liée
à celle de Monsieur Mélenchon madame la
députée vous appartenez un parti qui est
tellement inféodé à Monsieur Mélenchon
que vous en êtes réduit à demander à vos
propres candidats de se retirer du
deuxième tour des élections légisatives
dans l'Ariège c'est la démonstration que
vous ne pensez plus que vous ne décidez
plus que vous n'avez plus de
souveraineté et de capacité de capacité
à penser votre propre avenir et je me
souviens d'une interview de Bernard
Cazeneuve qui avait dit que finalement
le Parti socialiste était venu le
paillasson de Monsieur Mélenchon je
crois qu'il avait raison et je crois
même que c'est pire
[Musique]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Thierry Benoît
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre il y a un
sujet de réflexion qui persiste dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens
c'est le partage des richesses créées et
le reste à vivre pour les travailleurs
qu'ils soient salariés du secteur public
ou privé qu'il soit ouvrier commerçants
artisans éleveurs qu'ils soient issus du
secteur de la santé ou du secteur
médico-social lorsque les besoins vitaux
sont mis à mal se nourrir se loger se
déplacer il est nécessaire de
s'interroger sur les mesures qui peuvent
rapidement être mises en oeuvre pour
revaloriser les basses salaires et
travailler à un meilleur partage de la
richesse créée ces dernières ces
dernières années des secteurs faisant de
super profits ce sont révélés notamment
au cours des crises successives qui
frappent la vie de nos concitoyens et
notre économie le e-commerce l'industrie
pharmaceutique les banques les
assurances les centrales d'achat
international les entreprises
énergétiques les compagnies maritimes
d'afflatement les gafam il y a madame la
première
nécessité de revaloriser dès maintenant
les basses salaires et dans le même
temps taxer certains profits exorbitants
et disproportionnés et ainsi mettre à
contribution à du proportion de leur
revenu les secteurs qui réalisent des
profits très élevés ma question le
gouvernement est-il prêt à bâtir avec
les partenaires sociaux un plan d'action
une conférence sociale sur le reste à
vivre et le meilleur partage des
richesses créées et enfin le
gouvernement est-il prêt à se coordonner
avec les autres gouvernements de l'Union
européenne pour taxer les grands groupes
internationaux je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher
collègue délégué chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Thierry Benoît je commencerai par
la fin de votre question évidemment tout
ce qui est de nature à augmenter le
reste à vivre que vous avez mentionné
mais aussi le partage de la valeur
d'ailleurs je me souviens bien des
avancées auxquelles vous aviez contribué
dès 2019 sur la partie passion et
l'intéressement avec le groupe modem à
l'époque concernant le partage de la
valeur au sein de la loi pacte et
évidemment nous sommes absolument
disposés je dirais plus que jamais
avancer sur une valeur mieux partagée
mieux distribuer pour les salariés donc
la réponse est oui et tout simplement
oui vous avez aussi mentionné monsieur
le député Thierry Benoît la situation de
nos compatriotes en matière d'inflation
vous avez dit une chose très juste se
nourrir se déplacer se loger ça n'est
donc pas un hasard puisque en
l'occurrence le transport le logement et
l'alimentation sont aujourd'hui dans cet
ordre les trois postes les plus lourds
dans les dépenses des ménages il n'y a
pas de hasard dit les ai je lis mon pôle
départ il n'y a que des rendez-vous et
le gouvernement a été au rendez-vous sur
chacun de ces postes le transport la
remise carburant nous étions là l'aide à
l'énergie nous sommes là je rappelle les
46 milliards pour le bouclier juste sur
l'année 2023 pour que nos compatriotes
n'aient pas subir jusqu'à 200 euros
d'augmentation de leur facture d'énergie
par mois je pense aussi au plus fragile
il ne faudrait pas oublier mais vous
l'avez voté contrairement à d'autres
vous l'aide d'exceptionnel de rentrer la
revalorisation au mois d'août dernier
des minima sociaux déboursés étudiants
des aPL je veux aussi rappeler le
partage de la valeur que nos
entrepreneurs de TPE de PME ont déployé
depuis un an on en parle pas assez c'est
plus de 4 milliards d'euros une prime de
partage de la valeur pour plus de 5
millions de salariés ça a été doublé là
encore râpé le ministre des comptes
publics il y a peu les entrepreneurs ont
partagé la valeur faut-il faire plus
faut-il faire mieux la question se pose
en tout cas vous pouvez être assurée
qu'au cœur de ce gouvernement vous
trouverez de l'écoute et surtout une
envie d'agir plus en ce qui concerne
l'inflation nous sommes là et nous
continuerons je vous remercie monsieur
le début
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Legavre
pour le groupe la France insoumise
oui ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la Ville et du logement il
est beaucoup question de violence ces
derniers jours et le gouvernement Épron
à en faire porter la responsabilité à
quiconque refuse de soumettre ou de
baisser les yeux monsieur le ministre la
situation infligée à des millions de nos
concitoyens est en effet d'une extrême
violence la moitié du pays vit avec
moins de 1900 euros par mois vous avez
diminué le montant des aPL nombre
d'étudiants sont obligés de louer à prix
d'or leur appartement et cela c'est
votre politique le renchérissement du
logement à travers les loyers les
factures d'énergie ou les charges est
une véritable bombe sociale je n'invente
pas les termes ce sont les vôtres le
manque de logement sociaux est criant le
préfet de Seine-Saint-Denis indique que
dans ce seul département 118 000
demandes de logement ne peuvent être
satisfaites les les plus modestes
consacre plus de 40% de leurs revenus au
logement déjà le nombre d'impayés de
plus de 3 mois augmenté de 10% en un an
dans le parc social les expulsions
locatives reprennent de plus belles il y
a deux fois plus de 100 domicile fixes
qu'en 2012 à cela s'ajoute l'explosion
de tous les prix en 2023 électricité gaz
les habitants de logement collectifs
sont exclusives du bouclier tarifaire
des particuliers et toutes les charges
explosent oui une extrême violence c'est
pourquoi je souhaite vous interroger
allez-vous décider la diminution des
loyers en imposant un taux d'IRL négatif
allez-vous augmenter les APL allez-vous
décider le blocage réel des tarifs de
l'énergie et le retour au tarif
réglementé pour tous je vous en ai saisi
à de multiples reprises concernant
plusieurs copropriétés de ma
circonscription menacé de faillite par
l'explosion des tarifs de l'énergie les
bailleurs renvois des courriers
terrifiants au locataire annonçant la
hausse des charges et celle du prix de
l'eau d'ores et déjà les habitants
qu'ils soient propriétaires ou
locataires savent qu'ils ne pourront pas
payer
monsieur le ministre vous allez pouvoir
et la responsabilité de désamorcer cette
bombe sociale et je vous remercie
d'indiquer si vous envisagez de prendre
ses premières mesures d'urgence pratique
et immédiates je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
Logement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs le député les
député monsieur le député Jérôme legave
oui la situation du logement dans notre
pays est une situation complexe oui
comme ça a été indiqué par ma collègue
Olivia Grégoire le poste de dépenses
liée au logement est un des premiers
postes de dépenses de nos concitoyens
mais oui le gouvernement agit le
gouvernement agit avec les
parlementaires de la majorité d'abord
dans le cadre de la loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat nous avons augmenté les APL de 3
et demi pour cent et nous avons décidé
de plafonner l'augmentation du loyer
pour que les bailleurs sociaux puissent
continuer les nécessaires opération de
rénovation thermique oui nous avons agi
d'abord sur un bouclier tarifaire
individuel sur le gaz l'électricité il
est resté oui nous avons complété le
bouclier tarifaire collectif et vous le
savez sur le gaz et l'électricité et y
compris sur le les parties communes et
vous le savez y compris sur les
copropriétés de votre circonscription
parce que nous les suivons ensemble et
si c'est copropriété avaient fait les
démarches en direction des fournisseurs
d'énergie à temps ils auraient déjà reçu
l'argent auquel ils ont droit oui nous
agissons nous agissons pour qu'il y ait
plus de logements dans ce pays c'est le
sens du CNR nous ne polémique compagne
aux agissons avec l'ensemble des élus de
tous les bancs de cet assemblée pour
produire plus là où il y a plus de
besoins et je vous invite à indiquer à
l'ensemble des maires qu'il faut
construire et accepter l'acte de
construire nous oui nous agissons pour
les plus fragiles en lançant le plan
logement d'abord et en maintenant
l'hébergement d'urgence à l'état où il
était alors que nous l'avons nous
l'avons trouvé à moins de 120 000 place
d'hébergement d'urgence que nous sommes
arrivés c'est 200000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence et oui nous
agissons sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la part alors vous avez deux
secondes recevez moi monsieur le
ministre vous soumettrez plusieurs faits
je vous remercie la parole il me reste
du temps Madame le Président Monsieur le
Ministre excusez-moi
monsieur monsieur le député je vous
reçois quand vous voulez nous en avons
plusieurs fois parlé mais surtout je
vois les copropriétés en question j'ai
vu la Présidente d'engie il y a
non mais j'avais 20 secondes je suis je
suis un chronomètre dans l'oeil donc oui
nous agissons et nous continuerons agir
pas seulement sur les copropriétés de
Coubron et de Livry-Gargan mais sur
l'ensemble des copropriétés de ce pays
c'est notre responsabilité beaucoup
Monsieur le Ministre on remet le
chronomètre à 0 s'il vous plaît
pour le président marlex pour les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
de la République semble avoir découvert
le beau mot de souveraineté en parler
c'est bien pratiquer c'est mieux et deux
événements me mènent à vous interroger
sur votre détermination le premier c'est
le projet de rachat de l'entreprise
française Sego fabricant de
robinetteries de haute performance qui
équipe nos sous-marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins par une entreprise
américaine la conséquence la conséquence
de ce passage ce pavillon américain ce
serait que l'exportation la vente de nos
sous-marins on trouve ça à quel point
les pattes jours brillantes
passeraient serait soumise désormais à
autorisation du gouvernement des
États-Unis du fait de la législation
Itard donc pouvez-vous nous dire très
clairement que vous allez vous opposer à
ce projet que vous ferez valoir votre
veto de la part de ceux qui ont vendu
Alstom Alcatel technique vous
comprendrez que nous ayons des doutes le
second sujet important en matière de
souveraineté le second évènement c'est
le Conseil européen du 23 mars dernier
au cours duquel la présidente de la
Commission a présenté le projet
industrie 0.9 ce projet en l'état est
inacceptable pour la France puisqu'il
exclut la plupart des investissements
dans la filière nucléaire pour des
raisons purement idéologiques et
absolument pas rationnel alors je vous
le demande très solennellement madame la
Première ministre pouvez-vous nous dire
jusqu'à quel point votre gouvernement
est déterminé à se battre pour obtenir
l'inscription de l'ensemble des
investissements dans le nucléaire dans
ce projet de règlement
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Olivier marlex je pense que
nous pouvons nous accorder sur une chose
la nécessité de réindustrialiser notre
pays le retour de notre industrie c'est
à la fois un enjeu de souveraineté
d'emplois de création de richesse et
c'est enfin un enjeu sur l'équilibre du
développement de notre territoire et
monsieur le Président marlex depuis 6
ans les résultats sont là nous avons
inversé la tendance de décennie de
désindustrialisation la France a
retrouvé son attractivité en devenant la
première destination des investissements
directs étrangers en Europe et entre
2017 et 2022 ce sont près de 60 000
emplois qui ont été créés dans
l'industrie monsieur le Président Harley
Marley si l'industrie a fait son retour
en France c'est grâce aux réformes et
aux investissement engagé depuis 2017 je
pense aux réformes du marché du travail
je pense à la baisse de 10 milliards
d'euros des impôts de production dans le
précédent quinquennat et elle a
suppression de la CVAE je pense au
soutien du gouvernement à nos
entreprises au travers de France relance
et désormais de France 2030 avec France
Roland au 15 mars ce sont plus de 12
milliards d'euros qui ont d'ores et déjà
été investis et 2800 projets qui sont
soutenus ces investissements se sont des
emplois des chaînes de production des
compétences de l'attractivité pour tous
nos territoires alors vous m'interrogez
sur le cas de l'entreprise Sego un
éventuel projet de rachat n'en est cassé
début et je vous confirme que nous
serons très vigilants et quand tout est
à cause cette opération est soumise au
contrôle des investissements étrangers
en France quant à la proposition de la
Commission que vous mentionnez nous
sommes déterminés dans le cadre des
négociations au sein du conseil avec les
10 autres États membres que nous avons
réuni dans l'alliance du nucléaire en
Europe à convaincre que le nucléaire est
une filière stratégique pour atteindre
la neutraie neutralité carbone et
monsieur le Président marlex comme l'a
dit le président de la République la
réindustrie est au cœur des chantiers
devant nous au cœur des consultations
que j'engage pour bâtir un programme de
gouvernement et un agenda législatif
avec tous ceux qui veulent trouver des
solutions pour notre pays sur la
réindustrialisation c'est un sujet comme
sur d'autres sur lequel je vous propose
de travailler d'échanger de construire
dans les prochaines semaines nous le
ferons avec les forces politiques avec
les parlementaires avec les élus locaux
et je l'espère avec le pas les
partenaires sociaux à qui nous tendons
la main et ces deux cette manière par le
dialogue avec toutes les bonnes volontés
que nous répondrons aux inquiétudes que
nous apaiserons notre société
et que nous accélérons pour répondre aux
préoccupations des Français je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre monsieur le président
je regrette de ne pas avoir entendu le
mot souveraineté dans votre dans votre
réponse qui était essentielle dans ma
question je voudrais vous rappeler que
la semaine dernière nous avons voté avec
une très large majorité allant des
communistes gaullistes du rassemblement
national à Renaissance à 70% un texte de
relance du nucléaire je crois que c'est
un mandat très clair très massif qui
vous a été donné par l'Assemblée
nationale pour défendre cette filière
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
parole est un monsieur Christophe
Barthez pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente de mesdames
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé
monsieur le ministre 10000 ce seront dix
mille personnes qui se retrouveront 100
médecins traitant chez moi à Carcassonne
le 1er juillet 3 médecins ont déjà
quitté la ville le 31 décembre et encore
6 mai de saints feront de même le 30
juillet Carcassonne et ses environs à
l'image de la France sont un immense des
aires médicales voilà plus de 10 ans que
les médecins que j'ai reçu à ma
permanence vous alerte et alerte les
élus locaux mais selon vous tout va pour
le mieux de plus le zonage réalisé par
l'ARS à Carcassonne et fossé par exemple
beaucoup de médecins sont installés avec
l'étiquette médecin généraliste mais ont
une activité spécifique et possède que
très peu voir aucun patient en tant que
médecin traitant exemple les homéopathes
ou les actus compteurs acupuncteur
pardon quelques aides ont été mises en
place concernant les étudiants mais rien
de plus malgré la volonté des médecins
restants dont la moyenne d'âge sera
bientôt supérieur à 60 ans cette
situation est tendue sur tout le
territoire mais à Carcassonne elle va
empirer avec une très grande rapidité
derrière votre numéro d'auto
satisfaction c'est une conjoncture
catastrophique qui va se dégrader et
prendre en otage la santé des
carcassonnés dans de nombreux
territoires surtout ruraux ils
deviennent très difficiles de trouver un
médecin et d'avoir un rendez-vous dans
de brefs délais si des mesures d'urgence
ne sont pas prises nos concitoyens ne
vont plus pouvoir se soigner comme nos
aînés que vous abandonnez par ailleurs à
leur tour à leur sort
à cause de notre politique ils n'auront
bientôt plus de médecins traitant et
n'auront comme lien médical qu'un
infirmier ou une infirmière et c'est
encore Iliana monsieur le ministre
hormis pour le reste de la France en
général quelle solution avez-vous
précisément pour la ville de Carcassonne
et ses 10000 habitants qui vont se
retrouver sans médecin traitant à partir
du 1er juillet je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Barthez vous remercie de partager ce
diagnostic qui je crois est largement
répandu sur les difficultés de notre
système de santé particulièrement dans
votre secteur que je connais bien
puisque il y a Carcassonne mais il y a
également Castelnaudary il y a le Haute
Vallée de l'Aude avec Killian je me suis
rendu pour voir justement les
difficultés d'accès à la santé si les
problèmes sont dans les territoires les
solutions aussi je n'arrête pas de le
répéter puisque ces territoires par
territoire que nous construisons ces
solutions avec l'aide des plus de 250
réunions que nous avons conduit avec les
ARS avec les préfectures avec les élus
avec les citoyens pour adapter des
solutions à chaque territoire ces
solutions sont sont multiples pour avoir
l'occasion de toutes les détailler que
ce soit de l'exercice coordonnée que ce
soit les cabinets de groupe beaucoup de
choses qui sont d'ailleurs dans la PPA
de risque qui a été discuté ici et que
nous aurons l'occasion de revoir
rapidement en ce qui concerne les
réponses aux solutions qu'il y a elles
sont là aussi territoriales dans votre
secteur qui est particulièrement
innovant là-dessus en ce qui concerne le
monde de l'hôpital puisqu'il y a des
aides qui sont faits par les hôpitaux
autour en particulier par le CHU de
Toulouse qui intervient aussi sur
Castelnaudary pour aider la prise en
charge des soins urgence en ce qui
concerne les personnes sans médecin
traitant vous le savez j'ai lancé la
semaine dernière la campagne ALD 100
médecins traitant c'est-à-dire ses
patients qui sont malades chroniques qui
n'ont plus de médecin traitant ils sont
plus de 700 000 aujourd'hui la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
contacts un par un et pour un par un
nous allons retrouver une solution avec
l'aide des praticiens qui sont installés
et qui restent dans le secteur il faut
aussi aider au maintien des praticiens
les plus âgés c'est tout ce qui est fait
dans le cadre du cumul possible en par
retraite ou dans l'aide
concernant les territoires je vous
rappelle que les réunions sont
organisées par les ARS dans chaque
territoire justement avec les élus et
les citoyens pour trouver les meilleures
solutions la dernière avait lieu à
Carcassonne le 15 mars dernier en tant
que parlementaire vous y êtes bien
entendu invité à chaque fois mais je
suis désolé de vous dire qu'on ne vous y
a pas encore vu je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre monsieur
Barthez
ici dans l'hémicycle et je ne pouvais
pas être partout à la fois mais vous ne
m'avez pas répondu pour ces 10000
personnes précisément à Carcassonne je
vais remercier
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Servane Hugues pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
cette stratégie a permis de travailler
avec différents ministères santé
éducation nationale enseignement
supérieur travail logement elle a été
déployée dans chaque région et nous
montre à quel point la coordination
entre les services de l'État et ceux des
collectivités est essentiel et cruciale
dans la prise en charge du handicap
j'en suis persuadée le handicap doit
s'inscrire dans une politique globale
transversale dans une logique de
co-construction avec tous les ministères
ce travail est aujourd'hui largement
amorcé néanmoins et malgré ses grandes
avancées encore trop de familles
concernées restent isolées sans
accompagnement adapté ni solution de
répit des familles en détresse qui
hélasent parfois s'effondre alors madame
la ministre quel bilan tirez-vous
aujourd'hui de la stratégie 2018-2022 et
quelle suite est envisagée aujourd'hui
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Geneviève Darius sec
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
handicapées merci madame la présidente
madame la députée Servane d'abord je
veux vous remercier
d'attirer notre attention à tous sur
l'autisme et les troubles de
neuro-développement et d'avoir parlé de
cette journée du 2 avril qui est la
journée mondiale de l'autisme alors oui
depuis
18 la stratégie nationale a déployé 550
millions d'euros qui ont été de crédit
nouveau qui ont été mis en oeuvre dans
le cadre de cette stratégie structurer
la recherche d'abord vous l'avez dit 5
centres d'excellence qui ont été formés
structurés un groupement d'intérêts
scientifiques ce qui fait que la
recherche nationale est à l'avant-garde
de la recherche européenne aujourd'hui
et je crois que ça peut être une fierté
pour nous deuxièmement bien sûr repérer
précocement les enfants prendre en
charge précocement au sein de ces
plateformes de coordination 97
plateformes qui ont été créées et 41
000 enfants pris en charge au sein de
ces plateformes depuis qu'elles ont été
constituées
c'est assez important pour être souligné
bien entendu les dispositifs
médico-sociaux qui ont été inclus dans
l'école que ce soit l'école maternelle
l'école primaire les collèges
440 dispositifs médico-sociaux afin
d'aider ses enfants à intégrer l'école
de la République et puis bien sûr
l'emploi accompagné parce que ces
personnes-là accès dans l'emploi
également et on les accompagne à pouvoir
rentrer dans les entreprises et accéder
à des emplois de qualité et puis nous
avons bien sûr mis en oeuvre des lieux
pour les autistes avec des troubles très
complexes des lieux de résidence afin de
les protéger et de faire en sorte de les
prendre en charge de façon efficace
alors nous allons poursuivre la
construction avec une nouvelle stratégie
nationale qui est aujourd'hui en
construction avec les associations avec
les personnes concernées comme
d'habitude dans le handicap tout se
construit avec Association et personnes
handicapées merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Estelle
Youssoupha pour le groupe
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires au sujet
de son plan o alors que nous vous
entendons évoquer la sécheresse et le
risque de coupure d'eau dans l'Hexagone
je vous rappelle ici que Mayotte connaît
tous les jours des coupures d'eau
pendant plus de 12 heures et ce depuis
plusieurs années la situation est
gravissime et à l'Empire pour résumer
quand il n'y a pas d'eau de pluie dans
nos zones de stockage le système de
dessalement est insuffisant pour
alimenter l'île et quand il pleut trop
le système de filtrage est saturé et
produit une eau imbuvable hier c'était
de l'eau bleu Schtroumpf qui s'est mise
à couler à Kaweni ailleurs il n'y avait
pas d'eau du tout alors que la
population est en plein mois de Ramadan
impossible de cuisiner ni de respecter
des règles d'hygiène minimum dans les
foyers totalement à sec les
établissements scolaires ont fermé et
renvoyé les élèves en Petite Terre
Mayotte je vous le rappelle pdfactures
d'eau faramineuse pour des robinets
désespéré vide le préfet se refuse à
plafonner le prix des packs d'eau qui
peut atteindre jusqu'à 10 voire 12 euros
pour 6 bouteilles monsieur le ministre
vous allez me dire que 416 millions
d'euros sont mis sur la table avec le
contrat de progrès entre l'autre l'État
et les autres Mayotte mais rien n'a été
décaissé rien n'est opérationnel la
campagne de prospection de forage n'a
toujours pas commencé aucun travaux pour
la deuxième usine de dessalement ni la
troisième retenue colinaire je vous
rappelle que le Syndicat des Eaux de
Mayotte sur qui vous pariez et sous le
coup d'une enquête du parc national
financier nous ne pouvons plus entendre
dans la bouche de l'État ce n'est pas
moi c'est une compétence des
collectivités locales nous voulons à
Mayotte de l'eau dans notre robinet
depuis le début de mon mandat je n'ai eu
de cesse d'interpeller le gouvernement
ici dans l'hémicycle ou en commission
j'ai envoyé des courriers officiels pour
alerter aucun résultat qu'attendez-vous
courage agir oserez-vous commettre un
plan national haut sans rien prévoir
pour Mayotte je vous remercie
inter collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François carinco ministre délégué
aux outre-mer
votre question vient à point pour me
permettre d'exploser à la représentation
nationale des travaux déjà engagés et
les mesures déjà prises sur les
difficultés structuelles je vous prie
croix que nous y travaillons les projets
sont repartis depuis 6 mois vous le
savez vous savez pourquoi ils avaient
été bloqué les procédures concernant la
création de la troisième retenue
colinéaire et de la deuxième
usine de dessalement afin d'augmenter
les capacités de production de 5000
mètres cubes sont aujourd'hui débloqués
et j'attends les arrêtés publiques le
plus rapidement possible
s'agissant de l'usine de dessalement
actuel de petites terres des travaux
sont en cours afin d'augmenter au plus
tôt la capacité de production de 2000
mètres cubes jour supplémentaire par
rapport à celle d'aujourd'hui et vous
savez que c'est le gouvernement qui a
débloqué la situation les crédits sont
disponibles les procédures ont été
longues vous le savez
j'allais dire que l'administration
partagée à Mayotte étant à cet égard un
peu longue aussi j'avais demandé au
préfet d'accélérer encore davantage des
choses après votre dernier
interpellation au début du mois et c'est
ce qui est fait sur la sécheresse
actuelle
je suis Bill territoire devons réagir un
usit travaillant depuis environ 15 jours
depuis qu'on sait qu'elle arrive je
l'évoquais ce matin même avec madame la
Première ministre et monsieur le
Président de la République aussi j'ai
demandé aux deux grands distributeurs
présents à Mayotte de vendre de l'eau à
prix coûtant sans aucune marge pendant
les 6 prochains mois un des deux m'a
d'ores et déjà donné son accord et
j'attends l'accord du deuxième par
ailleurs je vous annonce que d'ici 15
jours grâce à la mobilisation de la
sécurité civile et sur l'instruction de
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur 400
mètres cubes jours seront disponibles
gratuitement pour les plus démunis
l'objectif est d'atteindre au plus tôt
900 mètres cubes jours gratuitement pour
les plus démunis je reviendrai
évidemment vers vous l'ensemble des
parlementaires Maoré
pour préciser les choses s'agissant des
procédures de distribution les mesures
sont prises et vous savez pourquoi elles
ont traînent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre tête
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
monsieur le ministre je vous parle au
nom des Français qui veut l'être soignés
proches de chez eux la loi Harris prend
effet le 3 avril avec des conséquences
catastrophiques pour nos hôpitaux
publics au centre hospitalier du Forez
sur Faure et Montbrison dans la Loire
les urgences fonctionnent avec des
médecins intérimaires aux côtés des
titulaires avec cette loi les médecins
intérimaires désertent et les urgences
sont menacées de fermeture la
revalorisation de 20% que votre
ministère annonce aujourd'hui arrive
alors que les services sont au bord du
gouffre déjà 70 hôpitaux partout en
France sont menacés par ces fermetures
au nom d'une logique comptable vous
épuisez nos personnels que nous avons
tous applaudis pendant le covid les
services ferment et les patients vont
être renvoyés dans des hôpitaux
surchargés qui deviennent des usines à
soigner monsieur le ministre si vous ne
suspendez pas immédiatement
l'application de cette loi vous saurez
le fossoyeur de l'hôpital public et nos
concitoyens seront en situation de
non-assistance à personne en danger nous
avons un conseil de surveillance
exceptionnelle lundi 3 avril en
sous-préfecture de Montbrison monsieur
le ministre ma question est simple et
sans détour quel message puisse porter
de votre part de plus au nom des élus du
territoire des personnels et de nos
concitoyens je vous invite à visiter
notre hôpital vous constaterez que sur
le terrain que les difficultés sont
réelles et que nos personnels sont en
souffrance merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la Santé de
la prévention merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député tête vous avez raison
si nous n'agissons pas c'est là que
notre hôpital public est menacé comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure ces
intérimaires mercenaires je ne parle pas
des intérimaires qui font leur travail
normalement comme probablement pardon
dans votre secteur mais
mercenaires qui jusqu'à la veille au
soir annonce qu'il ne viendront pas si
on augmente pas les prix de 1000 euros
ou de 500 euros pour la nuit ce sont eux
qui sont en train de détruire notre
hôpital public n'ayons aucun doute
là-dessus et il s'attaque
préférentiellement aux petits hôpitaux
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi qu'ils sont
les plus fragiles qui sont loin des
grandes villes et qui ont du mal
justement à maintenir leur ligne de
garde donc l'objectif est clair il faut
un signe fort par rapport à ses intérêts
mercenaires tout en valorisant
l'exercice des médecins qui tiennent la
ligne dans nos hôpitaux c'est ce que je
suis en train de faire valoriser
également leurs conditions d'exercice
valoriser leur pénibilité continuer sur
la ligne que j'ai mise en place cet été
pour maintenir les permanences de soins
la proximité vous l'avez dit est un
objectif majeur des soins et je lutte
contre cette inégalité territoriale
d'accès aux soins par plusieurs mesures
mais il y a également la qualité qui
doit être au rendez-vous et nous devons
avoir tous ensemble puisque comme je le
disais c'est bien tous ensemble autour
de la table que nous devons construire
ces solutions nous avons toujours avoir
en tête ce binôme la qualité et sécurité
l'intérim doit s'arrêter dans ses
dispositions inacceptables il doit
perdurer bien sûr dans des conditions
qui sont normales considérons ensemble
vous en serez sûr que 1390 euros brut
sans compter les frais de déplacement ni
de logement d'idées ni de nourriture
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
acceptable pour un médecin intérimaire
qui vient travailler je ne doute pas que
la grande majorité des médecins
intérimaires qui travaillent dans de
bonnes conditions et qui travaillent en
respectant ce règlement et en respectant
ce plafond continuerons à venir dans nos
hôpitaux pour les autres une analyse
précise est faite encore cette semaine
jour après jour sur toutes les
situations pour proposer des solutions
dans le cadre d'entraide territoriale ou
des solutions alternatives pour ne
laisser personne sans solution merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre à nos
chers mon invitation et votre venue
serait une forme de respect et de
reconnaissance pour les personnels pour
les populations et pour les élus locaux
je vais contacter votre cabinet et je
pense que sur tous ces bancs notre
objectif commun est de défendre
l'hôpital public je vous remercie je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude Rault
pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre la jeunesse que vous souhaitez
est museler celle que nous connaissons
est engagé engagé pour être entendu
parce que disons-le le gouvernement a
peur de la jeunesse il refuse donc avec
obstination de l'écouter et préfère la
mettre au pas si peur d'ailleurs que je
n'ose imaginer votre réaction après le
tournant de jeudi dernier ce 23 mars
sous la jeunesse s'est descendu en masse
manifestée ou 80 universités ont été
bloqués et que les lycées se sont eux
aussi mobilisés combien seront-ils et
elles aujourd'hui alors qu'on estimait
hier que leur participation pourrait
triplée
l'avenir que vous lui réservé c'est la
précarité quand ce qu'elle souhaite
c'est être émancipé avoir des droits et
un accès égal à la citoyenneté des 18
ans
depuis six ans nous assistons à une
accumulation de politique publique à
l'encontre des jeunes il est elles sont
frappés par les crises économiques
écologiques et sanitaires au terme de
ces six années la jeunesse est en feu
plutôt que d'être en fleur avec un
avenir à plus de degrés plus 4 degrés
logique quel serait chauffe hélas mais
ne vous y trompez pas c'est un printemps
de la jeunesse que l'on observe elle se
lève quand on lui répond par le mépris
et la force elle se lève quand on la
bâillonne qu'on l'étouffe qu'on
l'infantilise qu'on la laisse se
consumer elle se lève enfin pour ériger
une société où l'on peut vivre et
vieillir autrement et réenchanter
l'avenir
madame la Première ministre quand tout
ce qu'il est elle retiennent de votre
peu de considération c'est le vieux
slogan soit jeune et tais-toi que leur
répondez-vous quand assumerons-nous un
vrai devoir de solidarité nationale et
intergénérationnelle
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Sarah elle a écrit
secrétaire d'État chargé de la jeunesse
et du service national universel
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député vous
parlez de la jeunesse nous nous
l'accompagnons depuis 2017 nous parlons
pas de la jeunesse au singulier on
l'accompagne au pluriel dans ses
difficultés et dans ses espoirs ça
commence dès le plus jeune âge quand on
permet à l'école le dédoublement des
classes de ces pays de CE1 quand on met
en place les petits les repas des petits
déjeuners gratuits parce qu'on n'étudie
pas de la même manière qu'en a le ventre
plein ou le ventre vite on lui permet
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles quand on
passe à plus de 200000 jeunes qui sont
mentorés monsieur le député quand on
permet à plus de 225 000 jeunes de
partir en vacances grâce à Kolo
apprenante ces familles qui ne
partiraient pas pour autant c'est lui
donner de l'élan monsieur le député
quand on va chercher plus de 300 000
jeunes avec un contrat d'engagement
jeune souhaité par la première ministre
à l'époque ces 300 000 décrocheurs en
moins quand l'apprentissage dépasse tous
les records c'est l'accès à l'emploi
quand on passe de 24% à plus de à moins
de 16% de taux de chômage des jeunes
c'est le chemin de l'émancipation
monsieur le député on donne à la
jeunesse la possibilité de signer des
tribunes et des pétitions pour saisir le
ceseux dès l'âge de 16 ans c'est un acte
de confiance monsieur le député quand la
jeunesse elle a à la table de Matignon
chaque samedi parce que la première
ministre anime les scènes et les
rencontres de Matignon c'est elle que
nous écoutons monsieur le Premier
monsieur le député vous savez vous
parlez de la jeunesse nous on
l'accompagne vous l'instrumentalisez en
bâti avec elle je vous remercie madame
la ministre
allez-y mon cher collègue
demain à 11h30 esplanade des Invalides
l'alternative organise une distribution
alimentaire je vous invite toutes et
tous à venir échanger avec les étudiants
les étudiantes et avoir cette précarité
que vous peinez décidément tant à
combattre
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur le député 19 millions de repas
grâce au CROUS avec un avec le repas 1
euro pour tous les jeunes qui en avaient
besoin monsieur le député avec la
ministre Sylvie rotaillot et
Jean-Christophe 10 millions
supplémentaires gras pour aider les
aides alimentaires et les distributions
de repas 300000 colliers alimentaires
ont été distribués le gel monsieur le
député des logements CROUS la
revalorisation des appels la
revalorisation des bourses et les
travaux sont en cours à la table de la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
monsieur le député la jeunesse elle a
besoin d'un pays stable d'un pays qui
lui fait confiance et d'un pays dans
lequel et bien elle a toute sa place
c'est ce que nous faisons merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Estelle foleste
pour le groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Sonia Bacquet
secrétaire des tâches chargée de la
citoyenneté madame la ministre le
phénomène sectaire a beaucoup évolué ces
20 dernières années le nombre de
victimes est en constante augmentation
comme en témoigne les derniers rapports
de la Mission interministérielle de
vigilance et de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires
autrefois les sectes recrutés dans la
rue ont frappaient à votre porte elle
voyait chaque jour 10 ou 20 personnes ce
qui certes était déjà trop mais
aujourd'hui elle recrute sur les réseaux
sociaux et touche des milliers de
personnes par jour c'est un changement
d'échelle considérable en outre ce sont
souvent de petites structures des
groupes diffusés protéiformes qu'il est
plus difficile d'identifier
la menace est assis bien plus grande et
revêt d'autres visages ceux de gourou
2.0 qui fédèrent autour d'eux des
communautés sous emprise je pense à ces
marchands de bonheur qui invitent leurs
adeptes à vivre sans boire ni manger
assez pseudo guerisseur qui incite leur
victime à délaisser leur traitement
médical contre le cancer au profit de
jus de légumes ou encore à tous ces
soi-disant coach en bien-être qui
vendent à prix d'or leur conseil de
pacotille
face à ces nouvelles menaces l'action de
l'État doit évoluer la dernière loi
permettant de lutter contre les
mouvements sectaires la loi Abu Picard à
plus de 20 ans elle ne peut répondre
totalement et efficacement à ces
nouveaux enjeux les assises de lutte
contre les dérives sectaires ont eu lieu
il y a quelques jours madame la ministre
quel bilan en tirez-vous quel plan
d'action va être mise en oeuvre et
comment la représentation nationale sera
associée à la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chère collègues la parole
est à Madame Sonia bac S secrétaire
d'État chargé de la citoyenneté
dans la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés madame la député follès
d'abord je vous remercie de l'intérêt
que vous portez à ce sujet qui concerne
des dizaines des dizaines de milliers de
de nos familles à travers votre question
je remercie également toute la
représentation nationale qui a participé
dans sa quasi-totalité au succès de ses
assises qui ont été globalement
qualifiés de succès parce que l'ensemble
de ceux qui travaillent dans l'ombre
depuis des années sur ce sujet là était
heureux de se retrouver et heureux de
pouvoir travailler sur des propositions
très concrètes sur le sujet vous l'avez
dit les les dérives sectaires ont évolué
on est passé d'y à une vingtaine
d'années de l'Église de Scientologie au
Témoins de Jéhovah qu'on connaissait
bien à des nouvelles formes alors
évidemment des nouvelles formes en
matière de santé et j'y reviendrai mais
également à des choses nouvelles comme
le féminin sacré comme les écho villages
en autarcie comme le crudivorisme vous
en avez parlé et donc on a on doit face
à ces évolutions faire évoluer également
l'action de l'État et c'est
ce sont des propositions extrêmement
fortes qui ont été faites dans ces
assises et je tiens à saluer l'action de
ma collègue Agnès Firmin le Baudot qui
s'est engagé à encadrer les pratiques
non conventionnelles de soins c'est une
première étape extrêmement importante
mais nous travaillons sur un plan
d'action à présenter avant l'été et je
souhaite dans ce cadre inviter
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale qui s'est impliquée à venir en
réunion dans quelques jours à Beauvau
pour travailler sur la mise en oeuvre de
ce de ce plan d'action qui travaillera
vous le savez sur trois grands axes
d'abord l'axe de la prévention vous
l'avez dit avec un gros travail sur les
réseaux sociaux à mener un axe sur
l'aide aux victimes et puis un axe
évidemment sur la poursuite des auteurs
voilà donc je crois que nous avons un
gros travail à mener et je veux remercie
je vous remercier l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale pour le
caractère transpartisan de nos travaux
pendant ces journées d'assise merci
beaucoup je vous remercie madame la
ministre allez-y que je remercie la
médises de sa réponse c'est que nous
serons évidemment à ses côtés je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Béatrice
rouleau pour le contrat semblement
national
la question
son ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées à
la veille de la Journée mondiale de la
sensibilisation à l'autisme le 2 avril
prochain cette question pointe les
carences de la France en la matière et
plus particulièrement les difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontées des familles
pour scolariser leurs enfants
l'engagement en faveur de l'autisme
devait être une priorité du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron or le
bilan est plus que mitigé selon les
chiffres du gouvernement sur 100 000
enfants autistes seulement 42.000 sont
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire et 10000
en classe collective Ulis c'est bien
trop peu les familles ont le sentiment
d'être abandonnés par les pouvoirs
publics elle déplore le manque de
structure adaptée un nombre insuffisant
d'accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap et leur manque de formation
spécifique à l'autisme pour ceux qui
sont scolarisés les accompagnants sont
pourtant indispensables à une réelle
inclusion scolaire malgré un de la Cour
des comptes en 2018 et 7 condamnations
successives de la France pour
discrimination à l'égard des personnes
autistes par le Conseil de l'Europe il
est regrettable de constater que l'État
français n'a toujours pas engagé de
réforme d'envergure certes une maison
nationale de l'autisme va atterrir
inaugurée en avril prochain à
Aubervilliers mais pour l'instant cette
restructure n'est prévue qu'en
Seine-Saint-Denis pourquoi ne pas la
décliner dans d'autres départements car
permettez-moi de vous rappeler monsieur
le ministre l'article L11 du code de
l'éducation qui dispose l'éducation et
la première priorité nationale le
service public de l'éducation veille à
la scolarisation inclusive de tous les
enfants sans aucune distinction
qu'attendez-vous pour agir et permettre
l'efficience de cet article
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Geneviève Darius sec ministre en charge
des personnes handicapées
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée Béatrice roulant
bon vous avez raison il est un fait que
l'autisme et les troubles du
neuro-développement ont une prévalence
qui augmente de façon forte depuis la
fin des ou le début des années 2000 et
que nous avons véritablement besoin
d'avoir une stratégie nationale ce qui a
été mise en œuvre par ce gouvernement en
2018 stratégie je les dis tout à l'heure
je ne vais pas y revenir qui a mobilisé
550 millions d'euros par et avec tout ce
qu'elle a développé nous avons également
mis en oeuvre une délégation
interministérielle à l'autisme qui
structure cette stratégie et qui
continue de structurer notamment les la
recherche et tous les dispositifs mis en
oeuvre cette stratégie elle se termine
une autre stratégie va lui succéder oui
nous devons poursuivre nos efforts non
tout n'a pas été fait mais beaucoup pas
été fait je l'ai dit dans la question
précédente et ne reviendrait pas mais de
très nombreux pratiquement 500 nouveaux
dispositifs dans les écoles ont été
déployées pour l'accueil des enfants
autistes pratiquement autant ont été
déployés par l'Éducation nationale même
beaucoup plus les classes ULIS sont en
très grand nombre donc la prise en
charge elle existe elle n'est pas
suffisante à mon avis au niveau du
soutien des familles au niveau du
soutien des aidants nous avons besoin de
développer du répit et ça c'est une
réalité ça devra faire partie de la
nouvelle stratégie autisme nous avons
besoin d'épauler ces familles qui se
sentent souvent très iselés et enfin la
maison de l'autisme d'Aubervilliers
c'est en fait une véritable un véritable
centre de ressources nationales qui
pourra donc être utilisée par chaque
Français et sera relayée par des
plateformes dans chaque région donc vous
voyez nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
et je vous remercie de vous intéresser à
ce sujet qui est particulièrement
important et dont la prévalence augmente
je le disais tout à l'heure merci Madame
la Ministre madame rouleau madame la
ministre nous demande aucun vous croire
qu'à vous croire mais vous savez les
familles sont très impatientes elles
viennent me voir elles m'écrivent à
chaque élection très souvent alors ne
les décevez pas et surtout mais mettez
les moyens financiers je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Jacqueline Maquet
pour le groupe Renaissance
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé de la ville et du
Logement les difficultés d'accès au
logement sont au cœur des préoccupations
des Français qui doivent mener un combat
un parcours du combattant pour se loger
pourtant les tensions pour accéder au
logement risque de s'accroître les
prochaines années si les habitations les
plus énergivores du parc ne sont pas
rapidement rénovés en effet la loi
climat est résilience prévoit
l'interdiction progressive des logements
de classe GFE en 2025 en 2028 et en 2034
depuis le 1er janvier les logements
classés g plus sont interdits à la
location soit environ 140 000 logements
par exemple dans les hauts de France 40%
des logements se situent dans les
classes énergétiques EF oug par ailleurs
parmi les 576 logements sociaux que
quand ma région 27%
sont concernés pour respecter nos
engagements il sera indispensable
d'accompagner les entreprises et le
secteur du bâtiment nous devrons
également maintenir le financement
public des travaux de rénovation engagés
par les propriétaires et les
copropriétaires à cet égard ma prime
rénove est un franc succès et nous
pouvons nous féliciter d'avoir augmenté
son financement dans le PLF 2023 les
aides gouvernementales et les démarches
à effectuer gagneraient quand même à
être plus visible enfin nous devrons
accroître nos investissements dans le
parc locatif social et accompagner les
bailleurs vers les rénovations globale
des logements sociaux nous pourrions par
exemple atteindre l'objectif de 130 000
logements énervés rénovés par an pour un
financement de 500 millions d'euros
annuels ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre quelle mesure le
gouvernement compte-t-il mettre en place
pour s'assurer que les logements sur les
marchés ne deviennent pas vacants dans
les années à venir je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre en
charge du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Jacqueline Maquet merci pour votre
question sur ce sujet du logement que
vous connaissez si bien d'abord les
principes oui il est insupportable de
laisser vivre nos concitoyens dans des
logements qui sont des passoires
thermiques voire des taudis oui il est
insupportable que ces personnes est très
froid l'hiver et très chaud l'été et ce
principe nous dit tenons absolument
c'est pour ça que tout doit être fait
pour
respecter le calendrier de sortie de ces
passoires thermiques avec tous les
objets que nous avons déjà mis en place
vous les avez rappelé l'interdiction de
la mise en relocation depuis janvier
2023 l'interdiction d'augmenter les
loyers depuis le mois d'août 2022 et il
faut continuer à avoir cette ambition
aujourd'hui les propriétaires qui soient
occupants ou bailleurs peuvent avoir
accès aux différents aides de l'État ma
prime rénov dont vous avez parlé laissez
deux œufs qui sont une aide
complémentaire
des projets de réhabilitation l'aide aux
copropriété et nous devons y travailler
pour améliorer les conditions des aides
dans les copropriétés les plus fragiles
mais pas seulement pour que les
logements qui ne soient indécents à
l'intérieur d'une copropriété puisse
profiter des de la réhabilitation de
l'ensemble de la copropriété et nous
devons aussi continuer à travailler avec
le monde le monde bancaire sur le prêt à
taux zéro vous le savez qu'il est
accessible beaucoup plus facilement
aujourd'hui et nous continuons à
travailler nous avons reçu avec Bruno Le
Maire et Christophe leichu il y a peu de
temps les établissements bancaires pour
qu'ils soient présents à nos côtés pour
aider le reste à charge pour que les
copropriétés notamment et les
propriétaires puissent réaliser leurs
travaux nous allons mettre en place dès
la semaine prochaine une feuille de
route pour suivre la réhabilitation dans
l'habitat privé pour que ce suivi soit
régulier et nous tiendrons nos
engagements pour que nous sortions de
ces passoires thermiques pour que nous
sortions nos concitoyens de ces
conditions mais oui il est hors de
question d'augmenter le nombre de
logements vacants dans ce pays et oui il
est hors de question qu'un certain
nombre de ces logements deviennent des
meublés touristiques et nous y
travaillons tous ensemble
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Amar pour
le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cozy
ision territoriale un consortium de
journalistes européens établit que 17000
sites sont contaminés par les polluants
éternels plus singulièrement appelé
l'épée face leur représentation
cartographique indique bien que la
France est largement impactée par ses
substances de la Loire-Atlantique à la
Méditerranée en passant par le Rhône des
prélèvements réalisés des montres que
les eaux du Rhône jusqu'à la nappe
phréatique qui alimente en eau potable
plus de 200 000 personnes débordent de
ces substances polluantes à
Pierre-Bénite on mesure des taux près de
3000 fois supérieurs au seuil de
dangerosité nous connaissons les
multiples problèmes que peuvent
engendrer la présence dans le corps de
ces substances les hépatique maladie
thyroïdienne obésité problème de
fertilité et cancer du sud de Lyon à la
Méditerranée s'est contaminations sont
principalement le fait des rejets de
deux usines Arkema et Daikin spécialisé
dans la fabrication de polymères fluoré
rien ne les empêche de poursuivre leur
pollution ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
suite à ces éléments nouveaux
considérez-vous revoir votre plan
d'action afin d'agir plus vite et plus
fort sur ce sujet sans attendre 2026
comme vous le prévoyez actuellement
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Bachut
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Amar
merci pour votre question qui était
sobrement intitulée question sur l'eau
mais qui effectivement a un caractère
plus précis et qui vise c'est poli ou
perfluoro alkylé que vous évoquez c'est
au mois de janvier que pour la première
fois ce plan d'action du gouvernement a
été rendu public en 6 axes qui vise à la
fois mieux connaître faire en sorte
d'identifier accumuler la connaissance
puisque vous pointez un élément qui fait
l'objet d'un consensus scientifique qui
est le caractère éternel et permanent de
cette pollution vous citer également
cette enquête du monde très complète qui
ne vise d'ailleurs pas que la France qui
montre à l'échelle européenne et même à
l'échelle mondiale la manière dont une
partie des industriels au travers de
leur pratique fait en sorte de
contaminer nos sols avec aujourd'hui des
travaux de recherche qui se poursuivent
pour mesurer l'étendue exactes à la fois
des conséquences et des moyens de faire
en sorte de faire diminuer ces éléments
j'ai été saisi par le député Cyril Isaac
Sybille du souhait que une mission
parlementaire puisse de façon
scientifique creuser le sujet sans
mauvais jeu de mots du côté de la Pierre
Bénite et d'Arkema pour regarder comment
au-delà des plans d'action qui ont été
annoncés notamment par la métropole de
Lyon il puisse y avoir matière à
regarder si nous devons réviser à la
lumière de ces informations le plan
d'action qui a été rendu public le 17
janvier nous ne sommes que fin mars ce
plan d'action il a été déclenché il y a
deux mois et demi on est dans
l'évaluation sur la base des éléments
que vous rapportez ici du fait de savoir
dans quelle mesure on peut l'accélérer
sachant qu'il y a de toute façon des
mesures qui répondent finalement par
anticipation à ces révélations en
faisant en sorte pour la première fois
d'aller chercher des connaissances de
manière approfondie merci pour votre
question je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur Amar
merci comment vous croire Monsieur le
Ministre parce que nous attendons des
mesures concrètes pour prendre le mal à
la racine comment considérer que vous
voulez attaquer les problèmes qui est en
fait la cause de ce bouleversement
sanitaire et climatique c'est ce que
vous démontrez quand vous allez dans le
sens d'un modèle industriel et agricole
d'un autre temps avec des mega bassines
renoncer à ces projets écossides au lieu
de sacrifier des gendarmes des femmes et
des hommes autour d'un cratère vide
renoncer au matraques au LBD au gaz
lacrymogène
préserver l'eau et le vivant
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
un combat sur les perfus hollowers qu'il
est et vous voilà à la fin taper sur les
gendarmes et sur les policiers de
manière symbolique vous ruinez votre
question vous ruiner
[Musique]
la française les uns aux autres
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame Cécile Hunter
Mayer pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre de la justice si
notre préoccupation est centrée sur les
retraites cela ne doit pas éclipser la
question de la lutte contre la
corruption et le maintien des outils mis
en place plus que jamais ces
institutions publiques doivent être
mobilisées contre la fraude fiscale et
les narcotrafiquants véritable fléau qui
s'appelait fondements de notre
démocratie et prive l'état de nombreux
milliards
je veux parler ici de l'Agence Française
anticorruption
seul outil de prévention dont le rôle a
été salué par le CDE grâce à son champ
de détection et de contrôle étendu
elle est actuellement et depuis plus de
huit mois
privé de sa commission des sanctions
alors que le décret de nomination des
membres ne pose aucun problème de
rédaction
le directeur de la FA un magistrat
apprécié entendu ici lors des travaux
que nous avons mené avec Sylvain
vaserman sur les lanceurs d'alerte et
parti discrètement au terme de son
mandat et n'est pas pour leur remplacer
alors je m'interroge je m'interroge sur
la réalité de la politique publique
majeure qui est la lutte contre la
corruption pas seulement celle des
colles blancs monsieur le ministre mais
des narcotrafiquants qui prennent la
main sur nos institutions que
faisons-nous de ce combat en envoyant de
tels signaux de faiblesse
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministres de la justice
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Cécile Hunter Mayer si vous m'y
autorisez une toute petite digression
car je sais à quel point vous êtes
attaché au sujet justice je le sais
parce que souvent nous avons travaillé
ensemble et que personnellement je m'en
suis toujours infiniment réjoui il y a
de ça quelques heures le tribunal
administratif de Nantes a été à nouveau
attaqué
protégé par les pompiers et les forces
de sécurité intérieure dont certains
nous disent ce qu'ils ont envie de nous
en dire mais heureusement qu'ils étaient
là pour ne pas que les choses soient
plus graves
alors je vais évidemment répondre à
votre question le renouvellement des
membres de ce comité suppose que le
Conseil d'État la Cour des comptes et la
Cour de cassation en désigne chacun de
membres et nous venons d'avoir la liste
de ces membres donc le décret sera pris
dans les jours qui viennent soyez-en
pleinement assurés merci madame la
députée Cécile Hunter Mayer d'avoir
rappelé à quel point LAFA était
essentielle dans la lutte contre la
corruption important pour nos
entreprises que cette organisme
notamment dans le cadre des CJ et vous
avez souligné vous avez eu raison de le
faire que l'OCDE avait été extrêmement
élogieux à propos de ce dispositif
français sur les moyens j'ose également
vous dire que s'agissant du parquet
national financier celui-ci a vu doubler
ses effectifs de magistrats en 8 ans
que ils sont assistés désormais de 16
greffiers mais aussi ce qui est
fondamental au regard de la technicité
nécessaire requise de 8 assistants
spécialisés et d'injuristes assistant et
un autre viendra
compléter très prochainement la liste
des juristes assistants voilà vous devez
être pleinement rassuré la lutte
anticorruption est au cœur des
préoccupations de la Chancellerie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre madame
Hunter
merci monsieur le ministre était
important de l'entendre dans cette
émission parce que nous ne pouvons pas
abandonner un combat aussi majeur pour
notre démocratie et vous le voyez ici à
contrario de ce que nous vous demandons
la suspension de des retraites et de
calmer les choses en ce sujet au
contraire s'agissant de la lutte pour la
corruption contre la corruption pardon
et bien nous vous demandons au contraire
d'accélérer et d'agir de manière
amplifiée sur ces questions majeures
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue
la parole est à Madame FA pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
alors ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de la Culture madame Rima
Abdoul Malak je voudrais vous interroger
madame la ministre sur les 34 écoles
supérieures d'art et de design
territorial qui occupe une place majeure
dans le champ de l'enseignement
supérieur de la création artistique
elles offrent près de 8500 étudiants
après de 8500 étudiants une formation de
qualité dans tous les territoires depuis
2010 33 de ces écoles territoriales sont
constituées en EPCC ces établissements
publics de coopération culturelle sont
portées et financées en grande partie
par les collectivités territoriales avec
une participation financière du
ministère de la Culture mais une
participation qui varie selon les écoles
depuis la rentrée 2022 les étudiants
professeurs et direction ont peur pour
leurs écoles et se mobilise parfois
jusqu'à leur occupation comme l'école
talm à Tours elle doit faire face à de
grandes difficultés financières qui pour
certaines peuvent mettre en péril leur
existence en effet elle subissent tout
comme financeur une hausse importante
des coûts de l'énergie et des matières
premières et ne disposent ni du bouclier
tarifaire ni de dotation exceptionnelle
pour supporter cette inflation en plus
de ces urgences ces écoles posent aussi
des questions plus structuelles
relatives aux différentes implications
de l'État entre les esad territoriales
et celles nationales qui délivre
pourtant les mêmes diplômes je pense
entre autres à la réaffirmation de la
participation de l'État dans ses EPCC
avec une clé de répartition nationale
équitable à l'équité de traitement entre
les étudiants au statut des PEA ou
encore à la compensation de la hausse du
point d'indice c'est ce sont des enjeux
déjà repérés notamment lors de la
mission flash sur ses écoles en 2019
dont j'étais co-rapporteur madame la
ministre je vous ai attaché à ces
interritoriales je sais que votre
cabinet a rencontré une délégation
quelle solution à la voix conjoncturelle
et structurelle envisagez-vous pour
répondre à leurs besoins je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Madame Rima
Abdul Malak pour ministre de la Culture
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Fabienne Colboc merci pour votre
question sur un sujet que vous
connaissez très bien et qui permet de
mettre en lumière ce réseau d'écoles
d'arts assez unique et qui fait la
spécificité de la France en fait il y a
deux types d'écoles quand on parle des
écoles d'art il y a les écoles d'arts
nationales je pense aux écoles des
Beaux-Arts de Paris Limoges ou Arles par
exemple qui sont des établissements
publics financés uniquement par le
ministère de la Culture mon ministère en
a l'entière et unique responsabilité
mais d'autre part il y a les 33 écoles
d'art territoriales que vous évoquez
dans votre question comme celle de
Saint-Étienne Bordeaux ou encore tout
ranger le Mans historiquement ces écoles
ont été créées à l'initiative des
collectivités elles ont longtemps été
gérées en régime municipal vous le savez
elles sont devenues pour la plupart des
EPC comme vous l'avez dit des
établissements publics de coopération
culturelle à partir de 2011 donc elles
sont historiquement majoritairement
financées par les collectivités à 90% à
peu près
elles connaissent aujourd'hui
d'importantes difficultés financières
notamment en raison de l'inflation mais
aussi il faut le dire de la baisse de
dotation de certaines collectivités pour
certaines écoles au vu de l'importance
de ces écoles qui forment le vivier des
artistes de demain et malgré le fait
qu'elle dépendent d'abord et avant tout
des collectivités j'ai souhaité engager
plus fortement le ministère de la
Culture pour les aider à faire face à
leurs difficultés donc à court terme je
débloque dès aujourd'hui une enveloppe
de 2 millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires pour faire progresser la
part de l'État dans leur budget ça
correspond à une hausse de 14% de leur
dotation à long terme et là vous avez
soulevé dans votre question un certain
nombre de sujets qui sont des défis
structurels pour ces écoles il va
falloir s'y atteler dans le dialogue
avec les collectivités j'ai confié pour
cela une mission à Pierre Houdart ancien
délégué aux arts plastiques au ministère
de la Culture directeur aujourd'hui de
l'Institut national supérieur
d'enseignement artistique de Marseille
Méditerranée qui va me rendre ses
premières précon isations avant l'été je
voulais vous assurer aussi de poursuivre
la concertation avec les fédérations des
merci madame la ministre et la parole
est enfin Monsieur Sébastien jumelles
pour le groupe GDR
sur le ministre ce matin pas de poisson
frais à Rungis depuis hier nos ports
sont bloqués dans les hauts de France
chez moi en Normandie en Bretagne en
Aquitaine décrié sont fermés des
armements hackés des marins pêcheurs qui
crient leur colère c'est une grève pour
ne pas mourir pas de poisson à Rungis ce
matin mais demain si rien n'est fait le
risque est grand qu'il n'y ait pas non
plus durablement de poissons français
dont nos assiettes parce que nous
n'aurons plus d'artisans pêcheurs pour
les péchés
plus d'artisans pêcheurs si on laisse
l'Europe interdire les dragues et les
chaluts dont les airs marines protégées
plus d'artisans pêcheurs si pour toute
réponse au brexit on se contente d'un
plan de casse XXL son projet alternatif
pour lancer notre pêche à taille humaine
respectueuse de la ressource qui Eric
nos pores et pour chacun des 9000 marins
concernés plus d'artisans pêcheurs si on
ne répartit pas mieux les quotas captés
par les sociétés financières au
détriment des petits armements
plus d'artisans pêcheurs avec ce vent
éolien qui impose 50 parcs en mer des
coups de temps ils ont l'habitude d'en
essuyer en mer mais quand les grains
viennent de la terre dont le dos c'est
autre chose entre les projets fous de
l'Europe le bashing contre ce métier de
dureté de liberté un état qui contrôle
plus qui ne protège le modèle artisanal
des organisations opaques une
gouvernance qui préfère les gros des
senors Hollandais qui font ce qu'ils
veulent en Manche des côtiers contrôlés
à tout bout de champ ça déborde ce
mouvement partie de la base rattrapé par
les comités doit aboutir à un profond
changement pour donner un cap d'avenir à
la pêche artisanale une stratégie
nationale il en va de notre souveraineté
alimentaire de la relève générationnelle
de notre économie de notre culture
littorale monsieur le ministre prenez la
barre l'État doit protéger la pêche
artisanale je merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Hervé Berville
secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer
présidente monsieur le député Sébastien
Jumel le gouvernement comprend et
partage les inquiétudes des pêcheurs et
surtout je partage l'exaspération et la
colère face à la proposition de la
Commission qui viserait à interdire pas
dans 10 ans demain la drague notamment
et d'autres techniques de pêche qui sont
vitales pour l'économie de nos
territoires et surtout qui ont fait la
démonstration qu'on pouvait concilier
activité économique et préservation de
l'habitat
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès le 8
mars j'ai indiqué au Sénat que la France
était totalement opposée à ce plan de la
Commission et que le Président de la
République et la première ministre au
salon de l'agriculture l'ont également
redit et nous allons nous battre pour
faire en sorte qu'il ne soit pas
appliqué et je constate au dernier
conseil européen que d'autres pays nous
ont rejoint ensuite c'est parce que nous
croyons dans la pêche française et dans
la pêche artisanale que nous avons
défendu les pêcheurs depuis des mois sur
les TACs et quotas pas de quota il y a
pas de pêche et donc au dernier conseil
européen nous avons réussi à défendre
les intérêts des pêcheurs notamment des
pêcheurs artisanaux français c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons prolongé
par quatre fois l'aide carburant qui
avoisine désormais plus de 80 millions
d'euros c'est le seul secteur qui
bénéficie encore d'une aide carburant
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
lancé au salon de l'agriculture ce
contraste stratégique de filière qui
vise justement à mieux structurer la
filière la moderniser et notamment à
permettre le renouvellement de la flotte
et il y a 20 millions d'euros qui sont
disponibles dès cette année pour
moderniser changer les moteurs de cette
pêche je crois profondément en notre
capacité à surmonter les épreuves il
faut le faire avec beaucoup de lucidité
beaucoup de réalisme et beaucoup de
détermination et donc c'est ce qu'on va
faire dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines en simplifiant aussi
la vie des pêcheurs parce que on sait
que c'est irritants et bien permettent
enfin font que les pêcheurs ont
l'impression de crouler parfois sous la
pression réglementaire et donc nous
allons porter le combat et je sais qu'on
pourra compter souvent pour le faire je
vous remercie beaucoup Monsieur le
Ministre la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée je vous
propose de suspendre jusqu'à 17h15 et de
reprendre sur le vote solennelle sur le
projet de loi relatif aux Jeux
Olympiques